people of the internet
ladies and gentlemen hello and welcome
to Retro rackings who are live we are
here today trying out the brand new
update for Harry Potter magic awakened
how's everybody doing today good to see
you if you're watching this in the
replay Squad let me know in the comments
below shout out to the replay Squad
always appreciate you guys but a big
update today man big big big update for
the game and I'm actually gonna jump in
we're gonna jump in straight away here
there is a new chocolate frog sweet
spree
PVP mode
and it's pretty interesting it is pretty
interesting it seems a little bit more
casual not quite as hardcore but I'm
gonna do it here for a little bit
because I have a challenge a Time
limited task here where I need to win
two chocolate frog custom dual matches
and basically the way it works is this
candy gets thrown out if you get the
candy then it does like more damage to
the other player and you want to see how
many knocks you can get in
a set span Alicia what is up welcome
Elisa I hope I'm saying that correctly
welcome in Jake how's it going Jake here
as well Alicia with the nine months
let's go Dylan with the full one year I
think you're the first ever to hit the
one year Dylan I think you are the first
ever to hit the one year which is
awesome man
Dylan also a new dad shout out to our
buddy Dylan that is just awesome news
wow I'm already almost dead I should be
paying more attention here yeah like if
they get the candy
it it just
really does a lot of damage
I can't believe I'm already so low man
they must be really okay see like that
person grabbed that and sometimes it
actually gives you health like that time
I don't know what it did when they ate
the candy
don't know what it did man but it did
not help us very much I know that
I'm about to go down yeah see you go
down and then you just get instantly
revived like that right there oh let me
grab this candy come on I'm on it why is
it not why is it not giving it to me I
want the candy oh of course that candy
just heals
all right so they're up 1-0 right now
with that
it's like an interesting little change
up you know I don't know if I'll play it
a lot okay now see that's the bad candy
you do not want to get that candy bad
bad bad candy right there
oh no I'll see them my other wait how
did I just what
yeah these guys are just absolutely
destroying us here
so they're up 2-0 we're not even close
to knocking them
Crystal come on
still there you go
the crystal just Crystal's standing
around a lot oh I'm gonna try to like
hide under this right here see if we
could just hide here for a little bit
I'm knocked again man
all right so wait we're within within
one
dude you get so much MP I mean the MP is
kind of crazy maybe I just need to be
casting more spells
that's probably the problem here
yeah this is one of the many many many
changes
fortunately this doesn't like replace
anything this is just totally new
all right so we got a minute and a half
to tie this thing up
preferably Take the Lead oh look at this
we're actually
actually looking pretty pretty solid
right now
boom that's gonna be one right there
nice
oh we just we moved ahead
I need to get out of this glacias though
yeah I'm gonna go down come on come on
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on
there we go I need to get over here this
is giving out health
it's giving out health
get out of the whiz bang no is it tied
up it's tied up
I've never seen what happens if there's
a tie
basically we need our crystals gotta
step up here come on crystal no she went
down
that's gonna be GG's we lost by one we
lost by one
oh dude Jake you're so close as well
so close Jake at the 11 months
boost your power enhance well that's not
gonna move us any closer to getting our
goal right there is it because we need
we need to win two
we need to win twice at this strange
little mode here
Jason what is up welcome in
got to get back to dad duties
all I can say is step to the left and to
the right
step to the left and then the right
we'll try that we will try that
Stephie what's up welcome in yes uh
Draco was was telling us about some of
the new
some of the new positioning of some
things
apparently more okay look Health goes
down really fast I think it's because
everything is normalized
let me try to do this number here
I mean my health just got absolutely
Zapped
not sure that protego diabolica is the
best okay we need to grab this we need
to grab this we need to get out of the
there we go
okay so that just that one cast a bunch
of explosives there
stop getting so close to me Wing keep
your distance
and then you see you got the little
timer here so you know when it's gonna
oh no of course that was the bad one
just threw out the candy right on top of
me
okay that guy's about to go down
this should take him out all right
there's one
come on McGonagall take care of that
Cassandra for us yeah grab that candy
right there
very nice
more spiders let me save my incendio
right here
okay actually I think
is that McGonagall
something just absolutely wrecked those
spiders okay let me grab that candy
there we go oh dude look at that
a lollipop that's just going crazy on
these people right now
just going crazy on them
get a little Nimbus about to get another
point right here as soon as that person
goes down
I need to heal though man I need to heal
yeah just hide in the nebulous for a
little bit try and get some health
go ahead and drop that over there
take out their companion by the way uh
anybody started playing year three yet
year three officially live today one I'm
doing well man how are you
thanks for being here
Jason downloading the update now oh man
I'm about to go down
don't go down don't go down don't go
down it's okay we're up by three about
to be up by four but
yeah big lead right here big lead
hello world welcome in
retro Mort
oh man I haven't I haven't seen or heard
from retro more in a while
retro Mort is uh
he's in hibernation right now
I don't really want to use Ron when they
don't have mini they don't have many ads
on the field at all right now let's go
take out that niffler
yeah I think the name of the game here
and this one is just like lots and lots
of spam and grab the candies I mean they
did say grabbing the candies would be
key to winning so maybe that's what's
going on here there we go five to one
all right
got our first win right there
got our first win
star Geezer Tim what is up how's it
going dude welcome in
uh shobh Ahmed welcome to the channel my
friend thank you for subscribing
good to see you good to see you we've
met our limit for daily gold right there
Anna you haven't finished year two no
way
it's good man it's good people were
really looking forward to your three all
right we need to win one more of these
and then I'm gonna hop over to some
regular duels Tim how's it going dude
just popping in to say hey well feel
free to stick around Tim kick up your
feet sit back put on Magic awakened on
your phone and just enjoy the stream man
new spam deck it is I don't think it
matters what deck you're running in this
mode
look at that I mean just right away with
the acromantula Venom
right away with the acrimential Venom
yeah yeah get that get that get that get
that
oh wait did the oh dude people already
breaking out the crazy strategies they
had a Time Turner over here
and she actually grabbed it I think
no way
why are there so many spiders dude
spiders are everywhere
I've never seen that many spiders
all right so we are at a ever so slight
disadvantage right now let me drop over
here so I can get the yeah yeah give me
some of that give me some of that
healing let's go
all right so that's the bad one we want
to stay away from that
oh we've got a lead now oh and they got
the Death Eater
oh my gosh we we took out there clone
very quick right there all right there's
one point let's go
also
where's the me is it always this quiet I
don't hear music doesn't it normally
have music
your Ford Anglia is bug oh yeah I was I
saw your comment in the Discord Tim
so what happened it won't let you
won't let me claim any treasure file the
tickets got me annoyed oh man
because they took out
that was an intentional change they took
out the gold which I think is probably
the biggest negative of this update
a lot of people are not happy with that
one
because I mean gold is the main way that
you upgrade cards in the game
and not having that is
I mean we'll see we'll see with the
other new modes if if you get are able
to get a lot of gold
I already know for sure that you
you can redo the forest so even though
you get lanterns you can redo it oh wait
can I grab that yes and it casts a whiz
bang no way
it's pretty crazy
um you can redo the forest even in the
new mode but the only thing you'll get
are the thank you notes that's it
at first it made it sound like you
couldn't even get those though so I was
super confused all right we're gonna
have another win there we go nice five
to one
five two one
no way wait hold on GG you said you're
having the same problem you have a hole
Forbidden Forest oh that's weird it
won't let you do anything
Stephy said she had the same issue had
to wipe and reinstall self-repared it
and work reply to my tick was to
reinstall the game oh man
all right I think I'm done with that
mode
I'm just gonna play it play some uh best
partners for a bit
here we go let's claim our reward for
that though let's go 300 gold yeah we
need all of the gold that we can get now
also the off the path mode I can't find
this at all this is supposed to be a new
team exploration thing they added I
looked through the forest couldn't find
it anywhere so maybe it's coming later
perhaps
perhaps it's coming later
the field gauge showed it's nearly full
when you go to click on claim the car is
empty not just gold nothing at all oh
wow so yeah so it's not giving you
anything
and welcome into the new uh new
subscriber there
oh man I'm gonna terribly mispronounce
that jerryak jerryak welcome thanks so
much for following you're having the
same issue with the Forbidden Forest no
way
that is very very strange yeah I just
realized the music's gone
it's good forbidden forests
so I can see if uh
see what what's going on
because I've already done I've already
claimed some things in my car and I've
already used my two lanterns for the day
over on the new so this is the new side
over here guys deathly Dell is gone
haunted hollow is gone and it's replaced
by this into the woods mode
so basically when you go in you have to
choose now which path you want do you
want to go for gold do you want to go
for one of these Echoes right here so
positives
already noticing some positives here
because in just in doing it twice I've
already gained more legendary Echoes
basically than I have playing the game
all the way up until this point so
legendary Echoes are going to be a lot
easier to come by now you're just gonna
have to space them out you know daily
because you get two Lancers per day
you can redo it again and then you'll
you'll still get the thank you notes but
that's it if you want let's see
Bellatrix Newt Harry that's going to be
in the second one and then in the third
one right here you can go for Dobby
Hagrid or Weasley twins so that is a
good change the bad change though I
think is that if you want gold
you can't get it from your car anymore
and so you have to get it from this
which let me show you if I hit the uh
the breakdown right here so completing
it at level five is only going to give
you 800. I mean the Ford Anglia
overnight you could easily get a
thousand each day
if not more sometimes so yeah it's kind
of unfortunate that the gold doesn't
just uh
automatically refill because it was
great that you had that passive activity
but yeah if I go over and hit claim my
Ford Anglia is looks like it's work oh
Tim what does it say down here on your
uh
like your time ticking
so yeah now there's a look at the new
at the Ford Anglia update so it still is
kind of tied to your solo progression
so once you progress so far on the solo
side of the forest you're gonna upgrade
so you get better rewards with the
obvious removal of
no more gold
okay we got we got Dobby right there
I have a challenge for that too right
now a season challenge what are lanterns
a brand new currency Anna
because that's what this game needed
more of
they needed more currencies man
I'm joking they didn't need more
occurrencies but we have more currencies
here's the lanterns right here do
lanterns are distributed every day at
5am
so every day you're gonna get two fresh
new lanterns what I what I do like about
this is it makes it a lot easier to see
how many more runs I can do for rewards
because I was getting really confused
with haunted hollow and deathly Dells
like
I don't know how many times I've ran
this I don't even know how many times I
can run this and keep getting rewards so
I like that it's more clear now but yeah
it's kind of unfortunate it's only two
per day you can let it stack up though
you can let it stack up so like if you
don't play for a couple days you can
stack to as many as 10 lanterns and then
you can also use gems if you want to buy
buy up to six more each day
we can't get enough currencies right
right right Jenny welcome in good to see
you Jenny yes guys if you're enjoying
the stream don't forget to smash the
like button
really helps other people to find the
stream a great easy free way to support
the channel here
uh yes hello world I am Grand Master
actually hit Grand Master yesterday in
in Duos
which I had just been playing Duos way
more casually so I was taking solos
really really serious man like I was
grinding that grinding that grinding
that to try and hit
Grandmaster finally did it as a
free-to-play player
but then it kind of kills it I'll show
you guys why
so if you hit if you hit Grand Master
and then you reach 8100
you reach this point right here 8100
which was pretty easy to do I mean easy
not easy but I didn't feel like I needed
to pay to upgrade a lot of my cards to
get to get to that point however once
you hit this point right here it kind of
shifts into a completely different mode
so you know the band cards and
everything once you hit this point the
band cards go out the window
all cards are on the table and then
you're only matched up against players
in that pool so let's see what they what
do they call this the global duel to
match up with other students from
countries regions making it into the
world rankings
now the big change that they don't
really tell you about until you unlock
this
is if you're gonna go for this if you're
gonna grind and get this far you really
need to be experimenting with different
decks and have different Decks that you
are good with because once you at this
point you have to basically set three
Decks that you want to pick from so
these are the three that I've been using
of course my Bellatrix also a Hagrid and
then excuse me a Hermione that I've been
having a lot of fun with I just need to
get a really good legendary Echo there
and then before each match you'll get to
see the other person's three this is
really interesting you get to see their
three and you get to ban one of them so
you get to say okay they're they they've
got Newt Hagrid and Hermione I despise
going against new so I'm gonna block
newts so then they can't use Newt and
they have to pick from their other two
they get to do the same thing to you
though
and so that was a really big shift for
me because I had been I mean Bellatrix
was my like Bellatrix is what I've been
just rocking for a long long time had a
little bit of experience with Hermione
early on as well
um so that kind of threw me for a little
bit I knew that was gonna happen I just
didn't know when and I didn't know how
it actually worked in game
now the kind of cool part though is once
you hit 8100 you get three matches to
where it's like no pressure you're not
gonna drop you you don't lose any points
you can only go up so it's kind of like
using the potion they kind of kind of
like they give you a free free potion
um now here's here's the downside is
that's the point where you start running
into people who
have spent a lot of money on the game a
lot of money on the game and having
really you know high level cards so
I definitely need to if I want to keep
going further I definitely need to grind
a little bit and upgrade or you know
considering spending money on the game
if I want to which I want to support
these developers because I think it's a
really good game I just haven't decided
when and how much I want to I want to
dive in so hello world I know that was
uh I didn't even answer your question I
answer one of your questions your
Grandmaster right do you know how to
play the scrute
I don't think I've ever seen anybody
I
I have ever seen someone use a scrute
in the game
in in when I'm running Duos I don't
think I have I don't know why the
music's gone
the music's just gone
maybe a little uh glitch or bug
oh it has no timer at all Tim no way
oh dude yeah maybe uh maybe like stephe
said maybe uninstalling and reinstalling
will will help out
this is so weird I'm gonna have to
restart my game after this I do not like
the silence I like the music
I need the music
dude this is so this is so weird
this is it sounds so strange not having
a little Hype music in between
did I turn it off by accident or
something I don't know I'm gonna have to
check oh this is just this is so bizarre
so it's only the sound effects
well I don't wanna oh my gosh I just
a little late with the inflatus but I'll
take it
oh that was bad man my Hermione I didn't
even get to use the spell
and they basically didn't take any hits
from that thunderstorm
phone off right now by the lack of sound
this is too weird man
if we actually managed to bring this
back somehow it is absolutely insane
come on use
jeez man
yeah I'm about to go down but that's not
a not necessarily a bad thing right
there so you can easily get me up
all right let's get the nebulous out
nice expulso right there
oh I don't even run McGonagall either
that was I had McGonagall in from
playing PVE
d
yeah I gotta restart the game this is
too weird
it's too weird
slasher welcome in
yeah I'll show my decks here in a second
I need to change it actually because I
don't I don't even run that normally
dude imagine if this person pulled the
clutch nah not gonna be able to do it
with that thunderstorm running good try
good try I'll give you a thumbs up
sorry I wasn't a better help
oh it didn't it didn't even do the
little
this is so weird man
all right completely I'm just gonna
completely restart out of the game
Metatron happy Tuesday indeed welcome in
making lunch right now Jake let's go
dark heart join the Discord guys yes uh
let me see if I don't
did I set that to where let's see if
exclamation point Discord works over
here
we'll see if it works yes it does
there you go guys we got a great magic
Awakening community over in our Discord
we've been having so much fun playing
this game that's that's been my favorite
part I know I've said that many times
but the the community aspect playing
with all of you guys has been so fun
super super fun I'm I'm wondering when
are uh when are they gonna update the
social club stuff man
I thought those little uh Social Club
rankings and leaderboards like I thought
that was going to be something with like
each new season
but it seems like it's already gone
which shout out to our social club by
the way we finished top 100 got a lot of
nice rewards for it
great job guys great job
all right there we go oh no no no no
check check check skip skip skip skip
I don't want to get the copyright let me
turn off the music for a second
YouTube makes it where I can go back and
trim it out but it's easier if uh if I
don't even let it get in there at all
okay I think we're good now
supposed to reset each season Stefan
hasn't yeah I'm wondering
that was so much fun
and like I feel like our social club
like we haven't been doing as many
social club related things
since that got removed
we're not really removed
oh put music back on back put the music
on zero and then turn it back up fixes
it oh
good to know well restarting the game
apparently worked too all right so let
me fix my deck here so I'll show you
guys here's the Hermione deck that I've
been running
for Takeo diabolica that's the one I've
kind of been swapping in and out
um in Duos I've just been having a lot
of Success With It
I I know it's not a card that's used a
lot
you could also plug in orb of water
right there confringo right there is
pretty solid as well
then I need to change my second
companion because I do not run
McGonagall I like Sandra there in slot
two
keep Hermione at the beginning so this
is kind of what I run for Duos
this is my favorite solo deck right here
so if you guys ever run into me in Duo's
ban my Bellatrix
ban the Bellatrix
bomb box
just crazy crazy powerful right now
Cornish Pixies I think they're a little
bit underrated also the monster book
really really really good card nebulous
I basically just have in there to help
me hide from thunderstorm which
it's only 2mp but still it it's kind of
easy to get out of but if they don't
have anything to knock you out then it's
great you could just sit in there and
hide
the cats I like the cats a lot just was
able to upgrade them earlier today to
level 11 and then this last card I kind
of swapped this out sometimes I run
thunderstorm
sometimes I run confringo I've tried a
little bit of the pure totem locomotors
well and then uh explosives really nice
to have too
like having Haggard there at the end for
a little bit of extra XP or a little bit
of Health I guess HP
hahaha
awesome Hammer oh yes
from the God of War collectors edition
man
kratos's hammer
yes GG that's true you can use that as
well
inflatus costs one more MP and I think
it's just a little bit harder to hit
but
it is uh it is definitely a good card to
use as well and then here's my Hagrid
deck
which
depending on the day sometimes I'll run
locomotor sometimes I will run
um opal eye here
spelling solution the niffler for a
little bit of extra and then the cats
the bomb box and then also have a pug
node just for like that up close once
when somebody gets in your face when
they send a monster book it's good to
have incendio I think is like the one
card that I run in just about everything
it's it's a super versatile card I run
that in my PVP decks and my PVE decks
this deck right here
helped me a lot I should say help me I
was just having a lot of fun with it
I've always wanted to try a hairy deck
so I thought you know what let's do it I
got a decent Echo that had some decent
cards on it and it was actually pretty
solid in Duos I haven't really brought
it out in solos yet but in Duos this was
really fun to use really really fun card
uh fun cards to use here and in this one
I kind of just that's the one I used to
like swap out swap things in and out
all right so let's go ahead and put it
back on Hermione that's what I've been
running most in the Duos but I might
show you guys the Harry here in a second
too
anything about the Quidditch World Cup
game you mean the Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions I know they're doing another
play test
another play test so I think that is
their
gosh what is that the third fourth fifth
between three and five they've done
quite a few play tests for the game so
if you didn't get into the other ones
make sure you go to the website and
apply actually
did it already happen
I'm trying to remember the date of it
when it happened
but yeah that's that's all they've
really said man they haven't said when
it's coming out
and anybody who's played it can't say
much about it because it's uh those
people are under NDA
content creators and just
anybody anybody who's played the game
[Music]
#bandbella
that's why I'm trying to really work on
the Hermione although with in solos the
uh
protego diabolica
it's just it's too hard to
it's it's a little bit easier I think in
Duos kind of go unnoticed to hide out
for a little bit
especially using nebulous that can help
a lot but in in solos man if you throw
the throw down that potato diabolica
they're just gonna hit you with
everything they have it's kind of force
you off off your spot
wonder when we'll be able to trade dark
magic cards Dude I haven't gotten
crucial either that's the one card I
don't have I've gotten two of Avada
cadaverous I've gotten like let's see
I've upgraded Ron once
I think I've gotten like three or four
Mythic Ron cards just crazy why is it
taking so long never takes me this long
to get into to a game
see did I did I change something up here
I don't think so
yeah I feel like Duos I run into I see
more people who aren't like crazy crazy
high level
and I guess that kind of makes sense
right like if you're somebody who's put
a lot of money into the game then you
probably want to play a ton of solos
I mean every now and then you do you do
run into people even in Duos but I
haven't seen nearly as many high level
players in Duos as I have in
in solos
to be fair you don't have a lot of
cadaver either yeah it's like everybody
has that one card I feel like
but I've gotten every other card in game
including like when McGonagall first
came out I don't know if you guys saw I
made a video on that
oh my goodness this person's on a 13 win
streak dude yesterday I I was on a
14-win Duo streak
we were just rolling just rolling I
forgot who I teamed up with somebody in
um
oh who was it
somebody in expecto goes Community
um
Social Club
and we I helped them get to Grand Master
it was a lot of fun
crucio was in your daily shop you didn't
want to yeah and honestly dark hard I'm
glad I didn't do that
especially now with the with the coin
changes
I am I am glad that I didn't do it
because I mean it costs those coins are
so valuable
all right let's do this number over here
and then we're gonna throw Hermione
and the thunderstorm for three MP
thanks to the Hermione Echo
use a little Nimbus so we don't get hit
by the Full Burst
dude this team is destroying us right
now
okay let's try to hide out in the
nebulous here
throw that thunderstorm that should do
some good damage there
nice nice with the ivy right there that
was huge
all right see if we can get them up man
this this person right here
a ton of Health
we gotta start getting some hits on them
man
yeah Force you out of there
I feel like we're gonna be able to KO
this person but this matumbu here is
nice Cassandra thank you for blocking
that for me appreciate it
dude ronan's about to go down again
we've got the one where we can revive
him twice though
which everybody if you hit a hit a
certain level
if you guys use orbital water make sure
you move around I don't know why they
weren't moving around right there very
strange
allowed me to get out of it very easily
all right hey hey hey might be able to
turn this around we got Ron coming up
too
key is Ronan has to be able to revive me
hey wait where are they oh wait oh I
can't see them
I could not see them over there
oh that's so unfortunate
Ronan no are you out of movement cards
oh that's gonna be it
good try
I always like to look at the details see
uh
okay
5842 not not a bad breakdown
sometimes man oh my goodness matumbu
only to 28 damage holy was doing all the
damage there matumbu just sitting in the
back not taking any hits at all
kind of a pain to duel when you win
against gold what do you mean when you
win against uh gold
you can't trade crucio yet Jake that's
what we were talking about you can't
trade any dark cards for some reason
or you can't trade dark cards and you
can't trade like the Mythic Ron card for
whatever reason those are are untradable
King of the North you're still looking
for McGonagall the Ruby Keys should make
McGonagall easier to get especially when
they come out with that new magic pass
where you're going to be getting more
Ruby keys from the magic pass
foreign
yeah I'm hopeful at some point they will
add
where you can trade though I don't know
why they wouldn't
maybe just give something people
something to grind for that you can't
trade for
if you had a 16 win streak
yeah I'd love to get that 20.
I didn't even know that was like a
special thing though until I was already
I was already to the ranks that make it
much more difficult to do but man that
we had that 14 win streak going from
actually I think it was already in
I think it was in Grand Master
definitely in Diamond but I think it was
in Grand Master
oh you started at bronze and we're up
against gold or silver ranked players ah
I see
well sometimes I mean you could just
look at that as a chance to uh
I feel like you should get more points
when that happens
yes dark heart I have seen
I've seen posts that that uh the an ass
command dark card is coming
yep
there's so many like sources of news for
this game it's kind of weird
I feel like
the uh like the netease version
that one for some reason they seem to
get things first like that's where the
news tends to break first
oh I was trying to get out of it
no I'm not gonna let you hide there in
nebulous nice good orb of water right
there
see if I can help get this person out
whoa I don't know what that incendio was
for
that was pretty nifty I think they went
into nebulous but then uh foreign
get him
get a monster book
oh dude yeah big lead big lead big lead
come on oh I just missed with the
expulso
about to go down
come on Andy
there you go there you go there you go
there you go
man they totally turned that fight
around didn't they
nice orb of water right there let's go
oh they moved at the last second
oh my gosh dude
don't have anything to knock him out of
it
come on
come on fly
yes
let's go dude this deck has been doing
so well for me I'm almost every time I
win
I have the I have the most damage it's
kind of crazy
no James and I haven't played yet in
duels James and I haven't played this
game much at all together we we did join
up the other day for a it was a deathly
I think we did a deathly dough no no no
it was uh
it's either deathlydale or haunted
hollow we did
imperio yeah nothing on imperio yet
are the graphics better on PC I I mean I
think this is like technically this is
the mobile version
just running through an Android emulator
so
still still no official word on when
everybody's gonna get the official
version of the the official PC client
hopefully soon though
because yeah I'd love to see it run and
look even better that'd be nice oh we
got the same partner let's go oh they're
on a seven win streak too
but yeah I think I I much prefer playing
on the PC the phone is nice like if I'm
away and I need to just check in and do
the dailies or whatever
it's real nice to be able to have that
but I just I definitely prefer the big
screen and the mouse
to be able to like
that Precision for when I'm
I mean I know touch screen is pretty
precise too but I feel like I just have
even more Precision with this
avoid that exploso right there
and I fortunately don't have anything oh
they tried they tried to get me out of
it
oh wait they did they did get me out of
it somehow
hide in here with Hermione throw the
thunderstorm
dude this is a great combo the or one
player running the orb of water
one player running the
there we go Ron's gone
come on sometimes you can hide in the
protego diabolica or in the nebulous
like just on the edges of it
[Music]
oh you're getting hit by crucio I
couldn't help you there but you got out
of it anyway
darn it dude let's just fly out of it
here
they're using something to get me out I
don't know if it's Port key or what
nice job let's go
let's go
dude I should just send them an invite
we could just keep matching up together
I I will after this actually let's see
if they'll join
let's just join up
oh they've already joined a team no they
haven't
they have not joined a team there's no
way they've joined a team that quickly
yeah so no imperio no expecto patronum
either although I've heard that card is
coming at some point
the Azkaban one that's
that's not expect to patronum that's
like a dark card yeah it's kind of weird
that they would go with like something
like an Azkaban card before
before imperio oh dude we got Andy again
this is right
this is great I tried to invite you Andy
Elisa you added me as a friend nice I've
pretty much been accepting everybody
so I think you can have 150 total and
I've been accepting any any that come in
nice nebulous right there
let them all walk in let them all get in
close here
there we go
let's just back up that Cassandra a
little bit
well we definitely need to take out
definitely need to take out that
Thunderbird over there
it's at two Health come on
there we go
get Cassandra out to help with this
Norwegian Ridgeback okay she helped us
out she did she did her job
nice or nice orb
yep hold them right there
nice
it's a close one very very close
oh I moved
we go
exposure
oh I got Ron out just in time
come on Andy no get Royal get Royal get
Royal get Royal okay Royal
yes good call
nice
good game
Anthony is here Anthony welcome in
welcome in for a second I thought you
meant Andy I thought you meant the
person that we were
playing here with I'm gonna try to
invite them let's try to get out quickly
come on
they have not joined the team yet
there's no way they've joined a team
maybe they're just they're just
automatically readying up so
all right we'll just do it again maybe
we'll get paired up with them again
the odds are hilarious what are you
talking about GG
oh no we're going against Andy now no no
Andy we had a good run together
now we must face off on the battlefield
okay Andy knows all of my secrets guys
I'm sorry Andy
yeah Andy got that side-along Apparition
going
all right come on get to three
back
and I don't know about using ivy on the
graph there but
come on
yes
fantastic
we'll let who let the locomotor try and
take care of uh
the Norwegian Ridgeback right there
oh man our teammate's about to go down
nice nice nice
I tried to predict
that's all you can do man when they have
when they have it when they've got you
in orbital water all you can do is try
to guess the movement that's pretty much
it
dude pin dragon's about to go down again
come on pin dragon we need you buddy
we need your pin dragon
nice Ron nice Ron I love that Ron right
there
I'm gonna send Myron out now too
internet
[Applause]
come on
dude Andy's still got a lot of Health
man
oh my gosh I've revived this guy twice
he went down again
oh I was trying to get the nebulous out
pin dragon buddy man oh my gosh
what
I don't think I've ever seen one that
low
18 percent
bro I I gotta give some help there man
you gotta give some help
the odds when you still end up with your
partner from oh right right I actually
had that happen a lot
in Duos for some reason
man I want to we need to get back up
with uh
I guess if you just immediately enter
the next duel it makes it harder for
them to accept your invite I want to get
with Andy again Andy and I were rolling
yo guy welcome in
we're just here hanging out running some
Duos on the new update
trying to see how high we can get
on the uh on the duo side of Grand
Master
trying out this new uh I shouldn't say a
new deck but a deck that I don't have as
much experience with but been having a
lot of fun with it
games have been going pretty well so far
we gotta had a solid partner that we
matched up with a few times in a row but
last time that that most recent match
I did 82 percent of the damage in my
partner did 18.
so I don't know what that was about
all right you're trying the old protego
diabolica well
you're gonna play that I'm gonna make
your life absolutely painful
sitting on there
absolutely painful
look at that look at that look at that
we definitely came out in the positive
there
no don't come in here with me don't come
in here with me
I told you not to come in
we can do that too
I kind of hate the thunderstorm meta man
I'm not gonna lie
fantastic bomb I kind of hate it dude
[Applause]
are you in there
yes you are bro isma do something
no don't save yours
sometimes in Duos man
the strategy from people is so bizarre
don't save your stack
use something that's gonna take them out
exploso inflatus no don't come over here
why why do you keep coming over to me
sheesh okay like right now
oh my gosh just remind me please thank
you
[Applause]
oh come on revived all right
let's go we want it boom
boom
you loving the New Forest you've already
wait you just said your three was so
you've already played through year three
no way I haven't even started it yet
but I'm glad to hear it was fun I can't
wait
GG story is always your favorite you
love the drama I know it's like such a I
described it as when I played Hogwarts
Legacy I felt like that was reliving
replaying a a Harry Potter movie
whereas this just feels more like
reading a book you know it's like you
get these little more like intricate
little like relationship drama and
Dynamics between character I feel like
you get a little bit more of that and in
a game like this
do you have a streaming schedule no not
yet I need to get one don't I
no I I'm working on so many videos a lot
of the time that the stream schedule is
kind of erratic also it's summer right
now so I have two kids and we've been
we've been doing a lot of traveling and
once they get back in school which is in
like a month then things will get will
kind of settle down a little bit we'll
be able to get more of a schedule but um
I usually all Tuesday is kind of like a
a main streaming day sometimes we stream
at night though sometimes we stream sort
of like this time afternoon
but yeah I definitely want to uh
get more of a stream schedule
book
I see you back there
oh we gotta take that out
right now
I hate to burn an incendio on it but
oh come on
all right everyone
oh that's our ridgeback okay
all right Cassandra do work
do work Cassandra
all right blubomat over here
is getting low but this person right
back here
we got to get some more damage on them
Hermione going to walk right into the
diabolica okay
no don't go down why is everybody going
down
all right everyone
all right this is this gonna be big
right here
I don't have anything to finish them
like am I the only one who
cards to try and finish people off
come on come on come on come on those
you don't have
[Music]
uh yes that atmosphere charm is on me
my gosh you're down again no freaking
way
get out of that get out of that get out
of that all right you gotta revive me
come on come on come on
quick yes
nice essence of Disney as well I like it
holy
I can't move
oh you guys I shouldn't have said the
games have been going well
73 okay that's better that's better than
the other one that's better than the one
oh was that the same person
I didn't realize dark heart I didn't
realize
so we need Hogwarts Legacy DLC I
completely agree I'm gonna give it a
second
try to get a new partner
no offense is my no offense
you like the the story better Chad
that'll open an hour meetings only 20
minutes nice very nice
Khaleesi are you are you on
looks like Khaleesi's at Diamond
Jake have a good one good to see you
here
magic awakened solo Grand is real trying
to hit top 50 in a starting to seem
unobtainable
how high did you get up to
yeah once guy once I got to the point
where I think it's 8 100 where you have
to like set your three
my big problem is like in solos I was
mostly only experienced with the
Bellatrix decks I've been trying to
learn
some other good solo Decks that I can
use
I'll do wait didn't we just fight Ronin
I think we did
yeah Ronan running that
okay we got a protego diabolica in here
yeah go ahead stand on it
nebulous
but yeah once I hit that point guy oh
dude I love nebulous man
playing around with like the the
outskirts
gotta take you out
no get out of the way
oh come on why you gotta do Cassandra
like that
all right everyone
all right Ronan is getting pretty low
there's a crucio
looking pretty good right now gotta
watch out for that Bellatrix
or for the Death Eater I always say the
Bellatrix
on Hermione it makes it a little bit
easier to not worry so much about using
a
all right he's about to go down
I need to save that I need to save that
there it is
all right he's gonna go down with this
come on like why does no else
I don't understand why other people
don't fire off spells
when they're weak when they're Reviving
oh honey you're gonna throw that at me
oh I missed timed that I did not think
logic was gonna move
come on come on come on come on get this
get this get this get this get this
all right logic's about to go down so am
I
come on all right logic is down
yes
boom there we go
I've been enjoying the videos nice uh
appreciate it guy I've been having a lot
of fun making them for this game was
trying to play a lot of the game today
and then I'm gonna put out a video about
the
you know the big update all the latest
your 75th with 9 300 oh man have guy how
much well I shouldn't say how much have
you spent money on the game I'm just
curious or are you are you going trying
to go totally free to play
Nick and Angie welcome in rewatched all
the movies hoping the shows go in deeper
detail oh the yeah when they remake
remake the game or remake the games
when they do the uh the new TV show
Bella and Hagrid yeah I like Hagrid but
I don't know lately I've been having a
lot of fun with this this this Hermione
deck in Duos has just been destroying
for me
absolutely destroying
like I said being able to um
just sit in the protego diabolica hide
and nebulous it's a little bit easier to
go unnoticed in Duos I feel like we're
in in solos that card it makes a lot
harder to use but in Duos you can
you can hide out a little bit more
but yeah my Bellatrix is my still my my
primary when I have the chance
you're not totally free to play gotten a
season pass a month ago gotcha yeah I've
thought about doing the magic pass
that doesn't seem like too bad
Joe what is up Joe welcome in
did you figure that out what you were
asking me on Twitter Joe did you get it
working
because I used to use stream labs
oh my gosh it's isma again
it's isma again you guys
all right come on isma here's your shot
dude
turn it around isma Show Me What You're
Made Of
first time we played with isma they did
like 18 of the damage next time they did
like 23 or something
come on isma just just put out some
damage for me you got this
oh my gosh dude at least she got the
thunderstorm off
like isma do you like what spells do you
have
there we go all right let's get rid of
Ron let's get rid of Ron regroup
I should have waited for the lightning
watch this
oh my gosh dude
that's not how you play with it yes
sheesh man
look at this look at their health dude
bomb right beside me
dude he keeps saving for that stack of
Monster books man but that is just not
the way
thank you
all right everyone
no move move move
you're gonna have to revive me again
oh nope that's it we're done
oh guys
oh gosh I gotta look again I gotta
well it's going up each time you guys it
was it's up to 35 that time
up to 35 percent
learn things that you didn't know and
almost did stupid stuff oh from the
videos Eliza hey glad I was able to help
glad I was able to help David welcome in
dark heart you need the gold Bella
I will say the new update makes it a lot
easier to get specific ones that you
want
makes it a lot easier now I say that I
did the Bella path twice today and got
Newt and Harry but
I mean the fact that there's only three
if you do that one all week chances are
you're gonna get a Bellatrix legendary
what I also like about the update is
it's gonna make it I think a lot easier
to
to get better Echoes In terms of what
they have on them that's the key right
you know it's one thing to get the
legendary but you need it to have a
boost on cards that you actually use
take a look at the isma deck oh yeah I
should let's just see what they're even
using
oh my gosh that's why they're not
casting anything
dude what is this deck
you're running fiend fire
you're running total locomotor you're
running Ridge
you're running three cards that cost
seven
and you're not even a Hermione
dude
Norwegian Ridgeback
thunderstorm
bomb box
bro what is this deck
what is this deck man
oh my goodness whoever said that I wish
you hadn't said that dark heart
I wish I hadn't looked at this
now I'm just even more
discouraged I'm just gonna wait let's
just give it a little bit
wait three win streak that's definitely
not right
what why'd it say three win Street
that deck is the
right what
what is that and they're in Grand Master
that's they gotta be trolling dude
they just have to be trolling I don't
know why you would do that
ooh Bella with bludger and mantor moves
I haven't tried that one out yet
but I will say
the bludger can be a super annoying card
to go against
if you run it though it makes man score
almost a requirement though
so that's taking up two spots
yeah Jenny that's why he was hardly
casting anything because almost all of
his cards cost 7 MB and he's running a
Hagrid
that is one of the most bizarre decks
I've ever seen
you got to level 21 GG let's go
that's awesome
I am at level
which one's the dragon that's where I'm
at
is that 24
or is that like 19 I can't remember
no not night it's definitely not 19. but
yeah I'm stuck at the Dragon
atmosphere charm what a jerk
yo why are you going after me so
hardcore come on now
I'm moving too much here to start
they Arch kind of like keeping me on the
move
why are you not moving why are you not
moving when you cast that
this is
all right I need to help you out a
little bit with those
there we go
nice got the Hermione incendio too let's
go dude
come on move move move move they're out
of it now boom Another thunderstorm
nice
nope get out of it I went the wrong way
come on
you got it Sebastian
why are you not Reviving Sebastian
Sebastian revive
oh my gosh
the heck was that dude
thank you
explosive
unlike you I'm gonna prioritize Reviving
I mean I can see if you're if you're
trying to finish the person off you know
but not in that situation there we go
nice
if only we could give isma some tips on
the deck right Trisha welcome in yes
Sebastian I'll give you a thumbs up
man I thought Sebastian was about to
blow it though sheesh
I was about to say you did not damage Me
by much I knew it had to be close
yeah we should we should like message
message isma hey would you like some
tips
not in a mean way
just like how did you reach Grand Master
was that your deck that you ran
Jerry Eck hey no problem you're welcome
here anytime thanks for stopping by
hope you have a great rest of your day
David you might have to go your
internet's bad only see half the stream
what
like it's cut in half or you mean like
it's uh
low quality
either way David
that's what the VA it's for
it'll stay live here on the channel
and come back and check it out anytime
man
my mother-in-law sent cookies
and they are so tasty
they are so tasty dude
this is the last bite I promise
right here
homemade chocolate chip cookies man
it's really hard to beat that
really really hard to Beat It
oh pausing all the time
oh my goodness look at our teammate you
guys
are you allowed to say that on YouTube
now
I think you can say it now right
there for a while if you mention that
word it would like
you know there was so much
misinformation during that crazy time
yeah dude like I just
I mean I'm using thunderstorm too so I'm
not
I'm not saying don't use it but
he's not a fan of of that meta
like it's just not fun
to just Spam
that kind of spell
sorry I can't help you
nice we got Hermione with the incendio
cast right there that was huge
said see if we can get rid of
Cassandra here nope okay stay over here
all right fine fine
I don't know why you're trying to stay
by me
I prefer like good what are you doing
I prefer good spacing in uh in Duos
see like watch this because of how close
they were standing well the Ron we took
out the run early anyway but I was gonna
be able to get the run and and hit both
of them
with a little bit of it
get the little exploso and the nimbus
no stay away from me
they're gonna be focusing you hardcore
honestly it'd be better if you went
ahead and went down right now oh oh wait
wait wait wait wait come on
oh we just missed the expulso are you
kidding me
dude how is he still alive
he's been surviving at that HP for so
long
oh how did that not take you out
that one did though
come on hit hit
boom let's go
dude he he stayed alive for first
with only like 50 HP
that was crazy
yeah that one felt that one felt a lot
more even ggs ggs oh my goodness though
which Legacy big difference right there
in the damage
I know GG I I like dueling is my
favorite thing in this game like there's
all those New Forest updates there's new
story stuff
which I've already done my two Forest
runs for the day but
I was just
so looking forward to playing
more duels it's my favorite thing by far
which is why I'm so excited if you guys
haven't seen all the new custom settings
for dueling
you guys such that that is a huge W for
this update absolutely huge w
ow we're gonna be able to do custom
games now and we can level the playing
field you can balance everything out so
there won't be a difference based on
people's levels which is really nice
and I could even at first I was kind of
worried because there was one that was
talking about spending real world money
but now that I see what it is it's
actually pretty cool so you can do like
your standard tournament mode right then
you can do a regular custom match but
then the other one would basically allow
me to pay money
for these in-game rewards that are
basically a prize pool
so I could use the uh what are they
called Jewels I could use jewels to buy
the pack or whatever and then we could
set up to where the people who win the
tournament get the get the rewards
that's pretty cool man like when we've
done stuff in the past we did some Smash
Brothers tournaments before and we did
some things you know giveaways around
Hogwarts Legacy and stuff like we always
had to do
I always had to do things that I wanted
anyone to be able to earn so we would do
like gift cards and stuff which is cool
but it's not like I don't know I feel
like being able to give away something
like this would be a lot more fun to do
oh my gosh you guys it's isma again
dude
does anybody want to run Duos right now
please anybody want to run Duos
so I can invite you
I should just stand in the corner like
not cast anything I'm gonna I'm gonna
watch them this time
okay through a grop
Norwegian Ridgeback all right
this isn't what the book said
oh he did okay he just did a
thunderstorm all right all right we got
thunderstorm and ridge back
doing some damage here
dude why is this team not oh they've got
to reach back too
go get a monster but go get him
go get a monster book oh we gotta take
out this Death Eater though
come on come on come on come on
okay you just just put another Norwegian
Ridgeback come on hurry hurry hurry
hurry hurry hurry hurry
dang it
come on man we might actually be can we
win one with isma here
it's gonna be close
come on
yes
come on throw something isma
dang it we could have won it right there
nice took you out
don't have anything to be able to hit
uh
no I missed timed it
Hey Ron get back here
oh my gosh isma
isma we better not lose this
isma we had such a massive lead
is my revive me please
get out of the get out of the atmosphere
oh my gosh dude
[Applause]
okay they should be out of her fives
it should be out
oh we did it
laughs
we did it let's go
isma with the most damage all right I'll
give you a like this one
I'll give you a like for that one it's
because he actually got the ridge back
up there were a couple matches I don't
think he even used the Ridgeback
sheesh
oh my goodness
I think I could invite you guy
darn it oh because you're already you're
already in the so if I get up to 8 100
she had a win are you on my list
I think you guys have to be either
diamond or Grand Master but you can't be
past 8 100 of Grand Master
yeah I'm a grand master for solo as well
that's what I hit first GG was uh Grand
Master on the solo side
yes it's so weird I was like grinding
solos really like really focusing on
wanting to do it with Duos I've just
been playing it way more casually like
no pressure not really getting too into
it and we just worked our way up the
ladder and made it
see I've already redeemed my free item
for the day yo shadowing there you go
oh just silver keys I want some gold
keys man I need some gold keys
oh a pug no yes I'll happily take that
shadowing let's do this
I don't care if you're diamond
the friends you invited have lower dual
points so the points earned by victory
in this duel will be reduced oh
interesting I don't mean I don't really
care about my points I just want to play
ha ha
oh you don't be you could do it GG you
could do it
oh you're Diamond why would my points be
reduced oh I guess because we're going
against two diamonds
hey they're on a three win streak though
all right shadowing let's do it we're
gonna go on a 20 win streak right here
let's do it
let's make it happen
locomotor
get an app all right everyone I'm just
like so over that spell
go after Malfoy right there
nice Malfoy's done
isn't what the book said oh okay we
gotta keep an eye out for that that was
one AK a limb
now save that
I'll save it for that right there
dude Hermione the Hermione Echo is so
strong when it comes to
oh shadowing are you running a uh
Weasley twins
I think that's a Weasley twin
oh Norwegian Ridgeback let's come on put
the Norwegian Ridge back in there
no
oh you missed
you missed with the AK
dang that one's still got a lot of
Health
oh this isn't what the book says
um
all right we got the ridge back up let's
go
all right here comes the big push
that's one
oh dang it
Hagrid echo or Hagrid uh companion
good play right there good play
I think I
I've been hit by that
egg it's not necessarily a bad thing
because
there we go nice GG shadowing let's go
the first of 20 wins here we go it's
coming up it's coming up
we're gonna do this
I don't know how I'm on a four win
streak I thought I was
I don't know
I don't know I don't know if it's broken
or what but I'll take it
I will take it
foreign
yeah it just sounded so weird without
music earlier oh Shadow and you're
wearing it's two grand Masters here
all right
we got this though we got this
deformity and Katie man
nimbus 2000.
nebulous oh we both cast a nebulous
oh I should have stayed in the back
atmosphere I'll just keep walking back
again dude
nice exploso
and I'm Gonna Fly
Oh I thought I timed it just right
why can I not move
no no no no no no
nice
boom
get the incendio to take the one out get
the
a pugno and broomstick ready for the
next one
let's go
ggs again
all right that's two for you shadowing
two in a row
somehow five in a row for me although I
don't remember oh no you got three win
streak all right let's go
let's go let's go let's keep it rolling
keep it rolling
Butters 74 Utah rank two
and Heather Rose
I think they were both Grand Masters as
well
I believe they were both Grand Masters
dude look at the HP difference man 2500
and 2700 versus
both of us like
oh I forgot to cast Hermione
it's okay
that's okay that's okay that's okay
oh man I can't help you I can do this
success
ful fantastic
oh they're going after the egg
brilliant I've got just the idea
got one in nebulous over here
it's gonna be a close one
they couldn't find me
necklace
yes
all right everyone
no way dude
no way
dang man
that was a tough one right there
good try good try
all right let's see if it resets my wind
counter now
yeah I was like
so I guess it was accurate I guess we
started winning more than than we uh
thought earlier
Lauren Garcia welcome in
from New York City
how's it going Lauren
dude we're getting all the grand Masters
now shadowing
if you get tired of it
just let me know
like if you're not
um
I don't know how it works for you I
guess I guess you probably would earn
more points though right
your Grandmaster in Solo nice nice
don't even fall there
nice we got the ridge back on the field
oh the Tebow completely missed
nice
oh how you gonna do that to McGonagall
come on now
foreign
how are you gonna do that to McGonagall
yeah we gotta take that out that and the
bombs
not a good combo
not when you're on the other end of it
anyway
I wasted that
oh my gosh
Legends
I can't move nothing I can do
nice essence of Disney I love it
oh I went for the wrong person
nice
dang it man we just didn't have enough
to finish some
where
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on
no I'm in nebulous oh the the freaking
oh it's going to be close
no not the orb of water no no no no no
we got out we got it we got out
foreign
oh that was so close man
gotta take out these ridiculous
no how'd I go down yes oh that was epic
dude that was a crazy match
let's go shadowing
so many revives so many moments of
having barely any HP
epic epic epic stuff right there
yeah Grandmaster Duo duels shadow in
from the chat here from the community
joining up
trying to get them to uh how far are you
off in Grand met for Grand Master in uh
Duo's shadowing
give us something to work toward here
Roger what's up dude welcome in Roger
I know that battle was crazy
so many of the battles in this game can
they end up being so close oh wait is
this the same people we we just played
them I know we played them recently
Butters and Heather Rose they think this
might be the one we lost
oh just started I gotcha yeah how
whenever you're in Solo yeah that
happened to me too because I hadn't
played a lot of Duos
so then when I hit it it bumped me up
all right so we got a good grind ahead
of us we can get this though
like look at this difference though in
in HP man this is crazy if we actually
win this
I mean they just they just have
they just have crazy
health
oh man they are focused
they are focused on that egg
come on Shadow and we can beat them
we can beat them
yes we got Ridge back on the field
ladies and gentlemen
sorry
thank you
you gotta get rid of that Death Eater
finally
no way I was walking out of it
foreign
so am I get away get away get away get
away
come on shadowing revive me
Shadow and disconnect
no
all right everyone
dang dude
oh my gosh
we could beat these guys man I'm telling
you we can beat them
gotta stay moving gotta stay moving
no I gotta get out of it
oh we tried dude we tried oh my gosh
look at uh look at their levels man
69.
Heather Rose
users block messages
oh my gosh dude level 11 level 12 level
12 level 12 level 12 level 13 level 13.
11 12 11 11 11 11 11
12 and we still almost pulled it off
we still almost pulled it off
yeah like how do they have that much HP
that's kind of crazy man because
shadowing is pretty high level too I was
just I was just seeing earlier
shadowman's light level uh
okay never mind 45. so Shadow and I are
like in the 40s
shisha
that was epic teamwork Oh you talked
about the match before Roger yeah that
was a good one
that one was good too like we we
outplayed them purely on on damage alone
they just had more Health than we did
oh man
definitely money yeah yeah
I just don't oh man I wish they would
have a mode
which now I will applaud them for the
custom the custom duels you can actually
you can actually do that now like in the
custom duel so we can whenever we do our
tournaments we'll be able to make it so
everybody's on the same Level Playing
Field which is really nice I just wish
it would be like that for the
competitive
the competitive PVP mode as well
yeah I saw you switched over to Neville
all right
maybe to help
help get the ridge back up
oh great
oh no shadowing they are doing some big
damage right now
gotta take you out
I didn't even look and see what this
group was oh I shouldn't have wasted
that
thing about Hermione is I feel like I
can use my spells a lot faster
and not have to worry about it as much
oh nice Stupify right there
all right everyone
try to back up let Cassandra work a
little bit
oh he missed with the snowball
no way
oh they moved
I would throw We're not gonna be able to
take him out anyway right there we got
to get some more damage on this lady
oh oh oh that was crazy damage right
there
are you kidding me right now
dude that was one of the craziest things
I have ever seen
it was Inc it was um acromantula Venom
incarcerous incendio
and maybe one more thing in there
oh my gosh just absolutely
melted our health melted Ryan welcome in
dude how's it going Ryan good to see you
ice poison and fire right sheesha
our health just absolutely melted right
there
all right I'm gonna try
I mean this deck has been doing really
well for me but I want to show you guys
the the uh Harry deck
which maybe I shouldn't honestly because
we've been running into such high level
people today
I mean it costs 2 000 to upgrade
let's go Bella I'll try my Bellatrix for
a little bit
I usually don't run Bellatrix a lot in
Duos
I feel like she's bet much better in
solos but we'll see how it goes
I mean we've been doing well with the
Hermione too so
oh hey look who it is on the other team
our teammate from earlier
we won with him by the way but his
health was super low
he survived with like
50 HP for the last
last portion of the fight
Ryan how's your day going dude
all right I gotta change up my
look at this all of them right here
just free damage free damage free damage
oh goodness not another actor manchal of
venom
and where are my bombs at let's get the
yeah go on over there Ridgeback
take the bombs Pixies take the bombs
let's wait just a second here see what
they spend
yeah we need to get rid of that
oh I protected you guys at least
keep going mate don't give up
all right
nice take Ron out let's go let's go
let's go Death Eater or the win right
there man
oh dude The Ivy snuck in there and tried
to get wrong but she missed
she missed
let's go
that Thunderbird is out again man
gotta get rid of that thing
they're easy to take out but man they
have a lot of Health
all right I'm about to knock roshi here
nice esposo right there I don't think
we're gonna be able to take him out but
oh my gosh look at the Death Eaters man
look at the Death Eaters doing work boys
wish I could take out both of them
right there
no I
dude do I revive inside of the motorbike
no I don't can I get in though
oh you can't get in
it's unfortunate
oh my gosh they have so many
how am I down again
that was really unfortunate that I lost
Hagrid
fantastic
oh I'm dead
geez my bad shadowing
that one's on me
I cannot stay alive
yeah we knocked we knocked roshi
at least once maybe twice I think
let me see what my damage was like
yeah still pretty good damage
okay I'm not gonna make any
not gonna make any snap judgments and
switch back to Hermione right away but
I was just dying too much in that one
break at work for you Ryan just want to
say hi hey glad you did dude hope hope
your work day is going well
Roger new package coming your way yo uh
let's go man I'll keep an eye out
too kind of you dude
too kind of you
I think uh I think Dr sherbet was
sending sending a package too so we
might have
a couple to pick up here in a couple
days
a witch Noble
Monster books
oh they got a ridge back too
all right everyone
fantastic bomb
oh I was like where is their ridgeback I
couldn't find it man everybody is hard
focusing me
hey we gotta get Cassandra out
Cornish Pixies
foreign
box blocked the snowball dude look at
their health man we're not doing
anything to these guys
wow
let's get home where is the Norwegian
Ridgeback oh that's ours okay
I was like where is the thing
all right come on ridgeback do what you
do no
freaking Ivy man
dude this fight is crazy
let's go
oh I don't have anything I don't have
anything
double incendio not enough
wait where's that been all game
I think that's the first time they've
cast an orb of water
not the freaking Bewitched snowball
they have a Ron ready no way no move
move shadowing
no oh we got it off no way
oh my gosh
I'm gonna go down again
no
oh we almost brought it back
we almost brought it back
now I want to see what they had too
level 50 okay not like crazy overpowered
level 49 all right
I mean we almost we almost brought it
back
still almost brought it back
hellfurion
hope it hasn't wrecked you oh wow you're
don't tell you can't be referring to
yourself in the third person oh my
goodness
it's a magic thing
I know Roger it was still pretty close
it was still pretty close
trying to help shadow in here get up to
uh Grand Master and
in Duos
we've hit a bit of a a wall I might have
to switch back to Hermione I just don't
like I don't know I don't feel like the
Bellas is good for
for team play for some reason
wow okay aguaminty
will instantly take down a Cassandra
didn't know that
and glacias instantly takes out the
all right these people are annoying me
already
stupid
fantastic bombs
oh this isn't what the book said Cornish
pixels
essence of Disney
this is a crazy fight man
they've not really been even they're
just like countering everything we throw
out
that's all they've been doing so far
glacias Maxima instantly takes out Ron
too okay
there we go Death Eater doing some work
the book says
damage is already done though that Death
Eater did some crazy good damage
dude the glacias Maxima
I haven't really seen many people using
that
it's not a bad thing that I went down
right there come on you gotta move
Shadow when you gotta move
you were out of move cards weren't you
dude that team was just like so patient
that's a really strong team like they
barely they barely cast it they just
reacted to everything that we did that's
what they stuck with
yo Roger with the seven months
let's go Roger thank you so much dude
appreciate it
appreciate it my friend
you're out of move card Shadow one I
figured
all right if we lose one more with Bella
I'm going back to Hermione we were doing
much better
we were doing much better when I was on
Hermione
Malfoy's grp wait what's gr Malfoy's
group will cast glacias at the same time
as you and your mirror image to
you have a field of ice
that's crazy
I didn't even think I don't think Malfoy
I didn't even think they cast spells
don't they just run up and punch people
I know Hermione cast spells but I
thought the Malfoy gang just runs up and
hits people
uh
all right let's turn it around
here we go shadowing
Shadow is like I'm gonna try that
augmenti
it was just like
every time they used augmenti was just
like the perfect situation for it
dude another glacias
what is happening
all right everyone
myself
they got too many bombs out shadowing we
got to take care of the bombs
I just threw a monster look at one of
them
they did not even help
okay there we go that one's gone
that one's gone all right
yeah I'm switching off Bella after this
bye I just don't like how it plays
run over them Hagrid
oh my gosh look how many
look how many runs got
no no no no get out of that get out of
that
I'm out of moves again dude these people
are getting us to move around like crazy
and they're not even close to being dead
dude this is actually crazy
all right that should be three Death
Eaters
that's only two
oh I'm dead
all right that's it I'm going back to
Hermione I don't think we've won since
I've been on Bellatrix
I don't think I've won
since we since I switched to Bellatrix
too many losses in a row
yeah back to Hermione we go
the silence I know you know we were
trying to bring that one back
just not
not our game the past couple not our
game
all right regroup refresh
see if we can do this now
Sacramento
another big discrepancy
on
health
y
oh this is
potato
fantastic bomb
um in an acremental Venom right now
all right everyone
dude no way man
seizures Ron just goes straight for me
no
yeah this is rough man
this is rough
let's bring it back shadowing
I believe I believe
I hit everything else with exploso
places
wow
wow we are getting some tough opponents
right now dude
some tough opponents
we've started going down now Joe way
down way down way down
we had a good streak going
early on
but yeah we've been we've been going
down for a while that's like I don't
know five or so in a row that we've lost
the competition has ramped up we've been
trying out some different decks though I
think I just need to go back and stick
with Hermione
my damage was pretty pretty solid there
now I have cookie crumbs all over my
desk over here
they were good though man they were good
yeah I have some drafts a piece I'm not
too I'm not too worried about it though
because I don't really
I'm already at Grand Master and probably
not going to go much higher than 8100 as
long as I'm free to play so I'm just
I'm just rolling
just rolling
not not worry too much about dropping
down because I think they had like they
have a tier protection so I I can't drop
below Grand Master now if you make it up
to like the next level of Grand Master
you can drop back below that
yo Ellen what's up welcome in
welcome to the Stream
welcome to the stream GG or doing while
listening what rank are you in uh Duos
now GG
we could team up sometime
shadowing's like all right I'm tired of
people using this
oh my gosh they're going after me
hardcore here
over
has it been 10 months let's go Elwyn
thank you for the 10 months we've had a
couple people uh
in here today with big milestones
what you just did you mean to use that
on me
that was kind of weird
oh my gosh Luna is almost destroyed
we gotta start getting some damage on
this other player though
Evan Evan teal van teal
oh you're gonna be stuck for a second oh
they had to break off augmenti
to save the teammate
oh see if we can move away from that orb
of water
oh dude this is close
that one's down come on I don't have
anything to cast I have thunderstorm
though let's go
yes
there we go shadowing all right we're
back on track now
we are back on track you're still
Platinum GG nice you got it though step
by step that's right
you just did this trial Forest path
almost the same as before different
Buffs yeah I feel like it's a little bit
easier now
and I don't feel like the Buffs are as
good
so it's like they've turned down the
Buffs and I feel like overall made it a
little bit easier
it's kind of weird though that deathly
Dell is gone because that was like the
only place oh my goodness this ryuji was
really really good
we played them earlier shadowing
Ellen's got you by three months Roger I
haven't seen anybody uh I think Dylan
Dylan has the full one year Jake was
right behind him at 11. elwyn's right
there at 10.
I haven't seen anybody above the one
year
but but that does you know maybe I I
need to make some new uh
what are those things called the little
uh badges
I need to make some new badges
because I don't have anything for after
after one year
I don't get why sometimes it doesn't
protect her
I really don't understand that
oh we got to get them out of that the
book
oh no
yeah good orb of water
really good or really good orb right
there
all right Cassandra's about to be gone
but I'm about to have a Cassandra ready
I think I'm just inside this nebulous
right here
oh
no
oh the ivy they finally got tired of
Cassandra being there
nice love the acromantula Venom
keep them from just sitting on the
Ortega diabolica
Oh I thought you caught Ron in it
no yes oh he got her up though no way
no freaking way dude
that makes me so angry like we outplayed
them
but then because they get the res
I I haven't quite figured it out yet but
there's like a there's a strategy to
to win you die because he and I shadwin
and I survived longer
but then because we we were so low at
the same time
dude
there's definitely a strategy to it
definitely a strategy just spacing it
out mid man welcome in dude welcome
like right there we down one of them
because we staggered when we downed them
I don't know man like I almost wonder is
it worth it to when you see one of them
almost down but the other one with a lot
more health
not to even down them especially now
that everybody has the extra wand the
extra revive
but Shadow and I survived for longer but
we base oh
you've played him in Solo a number of
times man we were so like right there I
felt like that one was ours we should
have won that one
but yeah like I'm gonna start
prioritizing this if I see somebody low
and then the other one would still like
half health or something
I'm not even gonna focus on them at all
fiend fire
brilliant
no
yes
okay they got a crucio gotta be ready
for that see if we can get rid of the
Cassandra right then and there yeah we
did nice
all right everyone
Ron's almost down all right Ron's gone
I see right now Paulie is is quite a bit
lower
no get out of that
nice orb right there yeah yeah let's
focus this guy for sure
oh dude Hermione's running the orb too I
love it
all right we gotta focus on Haddon right
now
all right Haddon
it's getting low
nice
all right right here oh no
I think we gotta go for it now
come on hit that hit that hit that yes
yes
there it is man there's the strategy
right there res is op I kind of agree
Anna
especially now that they give Everybody
two
with the with the new wand skin
I kind of agree
I almost feel like it should be always
be one and done
uh Gary welcome in do you happen to know
why the blast in its screw and
three-headed puppy have higher costs
unless I'm missing something seems like
the MP cost and higher what's typically
allowed yeah so with those cards it's
kind of a weird
um
if you read their description
you don't want to use them at their High
MP costs what you want to do is as you
play other cards their cost will
decrease
so I think three had a dog I think
they're both what 14 maybe something
like that three headed dog starts out at
14 somewhere in there but then as you
play other cards it will go down so you
can actually get it all the way down to
zero
so it can be really useful in like
Hermione decks if you're playing a lot
of low-cost MP cards can be useful in
Harry decks
because you're going to run a lot of
lower cost cards with Harry too
but honestly I feel like both of them
see I don't know you got to be careful
with like how you buff them right
because if you buff them too much
I mean because people what people do is
they essentially just wait till they're
zero whenever I play them that's what I
do you wait till there's zero cost
orb of water
sectum sempra
inflatus
nebulous
potatoes
so yeah that's kind of how you have to
you have to play them in a little bit of
an interesting way
yes go work on that Ridge back
nice
sorry mate I'm done for
aquamanchula Venom
Norwegians
bring out the protego diabolica oh man
that
such a good orb of water right there
oh they got the bridge back
no way dude
oh the thunderstorm though just Zapped
him
oh we cast at the same time yes
let's go
nice nice nice
ggs shadowing again all right
we're starting to get it rolling again
starting to get it rolling
stumping you for a while Gary yeah it's
kind of strange how they're because a
lot of people don't even look to play
them because it's just like wait what
but yeah if you actually look at the
description on oh wow that's 16 for the
screwed I hardly ever see anybody
playing that that one I feel like could
use a buff but like I do see some people
play the three-headed dog
but yeah when the three-headed puppy is
in your hand its cost is decreased by
one every time a spell card is used
yo welcome to the channel
gee
oh my goodness I'm so sorry
Gil Herme gilherm
thank you for subscribing welcome in
welcome in
and then it's the same thing for the
scrute
and because oh no this one's so this
one's a little bit different MP cost is
reduced by one for each movement card
used
so for for the three-headed dog it's
spell cars for this
it's movement carts
someone's blast ended screw that attacks
random enemies every eight seconds at
the cost of its own health
yeah I'll just say I feel like these
could use a little bit of a buff
both of these I feel like
a little bit a little bit you don't want
to make them too strong
Professor spells welcome in how's it
going
mid man you've been playing almost all
day just finished year three it took so
long to finally beat the last chapter no
way is it tough
man everybody's already just like
blasting through it
I think it was guy or somebody earlier
was talking about
talking about they already made it all
the way through
[Music]
laughs
you butchered that name
well go ahead let me share share
pronunciation guide with me Anna would
love to see it
all right everyone
nice orb orb is so good
orb of water is just
yeah
it's good in so many situations
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa bow down tree
like I just love how with Hermione
you can use so much right there back to
back to back to back
uh nice job Cassandra
dude Cassandra didn't even die from that
it's kind of crazy
uh sorry shadowing I feel like I'm
leaving you to dry over here
there we go thunder hit it just the
right time
like see right now if shadowing goes
down
it's actually probably better to go down
now
because then if they Whittle my health
down
oh no I didn't get him I didn't get him
I didn't get him
all right we gotta get Theo low we gotta
get theolo
okay now now now now now
come on come on come on get him get him
get him get him no
no oh my God
and see now it's like a completely new
game
completely new game at this point
dang good try good try good try
it's like all about the spacing of when
you go when people go down
we almost brought that one back after we
went down first
and it's your time to shine yeah yeah
yeah let's go
Professor spells last time you were here
was Hogwarts Legacy released no way
yeah I'm having so much fun with this
game way more fun than I thought I would
be I'll say that
it is such a fun game and so many people
are just not even giving it a chance
which is sad
so many Potter fans aren't even giving
it a chance every time I've ran a poll
on my channel it's just like
overwhelmingly people say like not
interested not interested not interested
and then a lot of people complain about
the micro transactions and I'm just like
guys
I have been
I have put so many hours into this game
at this point and haven't spent a single
penny on the game
are there micro transactions yes
absolutely are there a lot of them do
you do they pop up a lot yes
but I have also gotten countless hours
of free content from this game
and I mean you guys know like I'll I'll
call it how it is man like if there's
things that are egregious
I'm gonna call it out
but there is so much content packed into
this game dude we're getting absolutely
destroyed right now
I mean absolutely destroyed
bro how is this guy still up
how is that
your health man
look at it
expenses
nice oh
I was not expecting the double Ventus
play with his chest
oh this isn't what the book said
oh we got it no way
I actually kind of worked in our favor
right there that they went inside
nebulous
why am I taking damage
places
all right all right everyone
wow that was a good team man
that was a good team
missing inflatus uh that was the last
game wasn't it it's all good
just because it's a mobile game it's
flat no yeah true
true and I mean I'm not like I don't
play mobile games I really don't
but mobile games have changed a lot over
the years
and this has quite a few
um
quite a few qualities to it that feel
far more like a fully fledged PC game or
console game it really does
oh here's the pronunciation okay
guillermi
Gila me or Gila May
that looks like me G or maybe it's g g
Laramie
eilerme I think guillerme
you get daily drops and bits to keep you
occupied yeah yeah exactly
just fleeing cards left and right oh
Professor spells yeah you gotta get as
you as you get up the ranks you gotta be
a lot more strategic that's for sure
that is for sure kind of spacing it out
Hermione lets you be a little bit more
spammy with the cards because
her cost is lowered when you use lower
level cards
can you explain why there are so many
Echoes while you get so many so you can
use those Echoes to upgrade other echoes
and the game really doesn't do like a
great job of explaining how that works
but yeah so all those like lower tier
Echoes that you get
you can use those to upgrade your
bigger echoes
oh my gosh we're destroying this
bin guy
but Paulie here has a ton of Health
oh
dang it Polly you moved it just the
right time
I'll go this way
like Paulie has so much health we gotta
get Paulie whittled down
[Applause]
do poly Polly's movement
he's just moving to the right places
every time
no don't go down shadowing
no
oh
might help convince people yeah if they
released it worldwide on PC
oh my gosh shadowing what's wrong with
us
we're on a downward spiral again
see if I can upgrade anything
nope and not even close really oh I need
to upgrade broomstick should probably
try and trade for some broomstick cards
you know what let's go with the hairy
deck
let's go with the hairy deck it's kind
of crazy but
let's see how much 1500 oh okay fine
man I'm starting to get low on gold you
guys
I've not been below 10 000 in
I don't know if I've ever been below ten
thousand like since the game first came
out
nah I'm not gonna do that one
Harry's another one where you can throw
out a lot of spells
if you if you're running him properly
he started understanding as you keep
dying yeah yeah yeah
oh and I saw Mia in here as well Mia
sorry I didn't see you when you first
popped in AKA swamp which Morgan
Guillaume okay there's another uh
there's another see Mia that was way
simplified I like it
but which snowballs
don't even bother of course I threw her
right into or is that our Ackerman she
live in them
dude they're running some of the same
things that I am
how to stupefy not knock people out of
it it's kind of crazy actually
no way that inflatist missed
nice
I'm about to go down
oh
no
come on
oh I was trying to get Ron out
oh let's go we got him
wow that was kind of crazy right there
wasn't it
a lot of revives going on
I just don't I don't feel like matches
should be decided by
how well you like revive but I don't
know I guess that's part of it I guess
that's part of it with Duos I guess if
you don't want to worry about revives
then you play solos whoops I don't want
to leave
yeah the hairy deck I don't know is
there something about it it's kind of
fun to play
using Dobby for movement yeah Dobby can
you don't see a lot of dobbies in the
Dual dueling mode so when people do have
them it can it can definitely throw
people off
when you're teleporting around like that
zodiac welcome how's it going zodiac
but yeah uh Joe I wish they would hurry
up and release it on PC everywhere too
although I I like don't even think about
it as much because I'm playing the
emulator
how did that Miss no way that Miss
ES
no I missed him with the inflators
done for just
hug now
and that took out both Cassandra's
that's very unfortunate
very very unfortunate
dude why am I all of a sudden getting
people running the same stuff that I am
so weird
like as soon as I switched to Harry now
we're seeing multiple people running
stupefy and
even just another example what do you
want
now you're in trouble now I am out of
that incendio
yes
I love doing going for the Snipes with
the witch snowball
going after the Death Eater like trying
to hit him just right
this isn't what the book said
I was gonna say yeah like look at how is
this person have so much health
no way she has that much health
ier
oh my gosh perfect movement actually no
just barely caught her
okay we're getting some good damage now
bad timing on when I went down right
there
oh no I cast and played us
oh come on we can win this right here we
can win this right here we can win this
right here
oh no
oh we just needed one more attack
we just needed one more attack
oh man
oh my gosh she got me up somehow
I have no idea how
man we missed our chance we missed our
chance
the server I'm on opal eye
oh shadowing we had it we had it
the premise with Harry deck so with
Harry decks any spell that is
three MP or less
he does more damage with it I think it's
three it's either three or four pretty
sure it's three though
whoops wrong button
yeah enhances spell cards with an MP
cost of three or lower so they receive a
47 damage increase
just pretty pretty strong
so like that's why I'm only running
incendio is the only thing that I'm
running above before it's like all these
are getting a 45 boost versus what they
would do normally
whoops I keep hitting that by accident
it's a Yule Ball song
oh did did they update the uh
the dancing stuff I haven't even checked
the dancing mini game see if there's
anything else
ma does not have wheel
what's Ma I don't know what Ma is
opala is not getting all of the content
I have no idea what you're talking about
bazookas clarify for me
this is
no way that missed
where are they hiding in there
oh my gosh they are coming after me like
crazy
they are so focused
oh we got her yes
it's like hairy decks are another one
where if you just like throwing out a
lot of spells
then it's one where you can pretty much
do that
what do you want
it's like 40. now you're in trouble
no I threw it at just the wrong time
we're in this
I'll get you here
nice Ron nice Ron
they're still up big on HP somehow
oh they got a McGonagall hiding in there
no no
oh my gosh they're so close
I'll do bazook is never clarified I have
no idea what you're talking about opal I
not getting all the content why would
they why would they not give certain
servers
I don't understand
oh there we go we didn't get the new
wheel with the wand costumes Furniture
isn't all that coming though
oh yeah if anybody else wants to play
let me know if you're at Grand Master
you have to be grand master or Diamond
but below 8100
isn't that coming to Opel eye eventually
because I even have a uh like I have a
task right now for off the path
they already have it but right are we
gonna get it
surely we're gonna get it I mean I like
why would I have that task if they're
not gonna bring it eventually and that's
what the patch notes said for everybody
that'd be really weird if they only
brought it out in certain areas
off the path is there what where's off
the path
I looked everywhere for it
I looked everywhere in uh
I found the other uh Forest The New
Forest mode
into the woods I think it's called
but off the path is
oh yeah you're thinking of the other one
Jenny
the uh into the woods I think it is
is what they call it
but yeah off the path is not it's not in
there yet
despite the fact that it's in I have a
quest for it
so I'm I think we'll get it eventually
plazookas
like why why would we not get it
eventually
I know it's not in there right now
I kind of miss not having nebulous
with uh the crazy um
meta that is thunderstorm right now
thunderstorm is just like a Mindless
oh man this one's a this is a rough one
Shadow shadowing
it is rough
oh my gosh that might be the fastest
we've lost today
[Music]
yeah plazookas I'm gonna I'm gonna need
a I'm gonna need a link or something
that says we're not gonna get it
I'm gonna need a link that says it will
not be coming to other territories to
other regions
because right now
all I know is
it's not here right now
doesn't mean we're not gonna get it
have I gotten a certain invitation for a
game related to Bluetooth explained
twice for yes
I feel like everybody should have gotten
that at this point Joe with how many
they've done
I feel like anybody who wanted a chance
to play
one Harry Potter Quidditch champions
should have gotten a chance at it by now
but who knows maybe not
maybe not
yes see so this mode is here this is the
new mode Into the Woods
but yeah there's also supposed to be one
called
off the path this right here
so I think that they were they would
plan I think they're planning to bring
it in
attend divination class oh man I need to
take some of these exams
I this is an annoying one though guys I
got this
this uh season challenge here and it
says zero of six however I have already
done
so many exams
okay wait a second
let me back out of this
I've already done so many exams I don't
know why it wouldn't count
okay today's classes Hogwarts exam week
yeah see look at that
I'm already up to the a level in all of
these
hey Tom welcome in
good to see you Tom I'm doing well how
about you
other servers have it
who share duels with us and launched at
the same time and we don't is that a
problem
not to mention it with the passion notes
oh I agree with you yeah I agree with
you that it's weird like why why
wouldn't we have it
but I just don't think I don't think
that it's never going to come to opalai
that would be an even bigger problem
but yeah I I agree that it's it's weird
that it wouldn't just be life for
everybody
a good good game shadowing we hey at
least we had a few good ones on the
beginning there
and then a couple good ones in between
some tough games too
but nice playing with you won't let me
in any of them I try to go in it just
says reload no way Trisha is so like
oh no I might have to like
okay let's try let's see if it'll let me
go in
oh wait so I could retake
I could retake ones we've already done
if it works
oh man oh it is it is working all right
I guess I'm just gonna do it six times
on an easy level
man this one is so hard as it gets to
higher levels
so hard these little uh
these little thunderstorm things that go
around these little windstorms do crazy
damage
and I actually hit him up there I don't
think I can I think I have to take out
all the little ones
bazooka is no no I'm I'm agreeing with
you on that
I think it's weird too
it just sounded like you were saying
that we're never gonna get it
which I don't think is the case
I think we will get it it's just a
matter of when
why don't we have it yet that that is a
valid question
yeah hairy dick probably not the best
for this
it's probably not the best
there we go
excuse me oh for outstanding is the
highest you can get yeah yeah
I know I can't believe that they didn't
have that like have the those grades Joe
it's kind of crazy
all right so let's see what are the
other ones that one takes a long time
this one might not take too long
but yeah look at that the the level I
met right now A plus you need a spell
book level of 80. well that's what's
what's recommended anyway
oh you can't use Cassandra
come on now why not
see what would be a good deck for these
it's the trolls I'll do this one
just have to swap Cassandra out there
let's move Ron to the front as well
maybe it was doing this for you uh
foreign like mine kind of had a little
delay like when I clicked it
it didn't activate right away
wait what
oh all right everyone we're in this
video
when guardian Leviosa
let's see which one's faster and then
just keep doing that one for four more
times
oh we launched him right in the middle
of it
I think this one's going faster than the
then the hippogriff one
I should just run like whiz-bang
oh wow that
very poor aim on that one right there
is it just me or does this this exam
right here feel like it's bugged or
something
it doesn't feel like it's working the
way it's supposed to
because they give you this card when
guardian Leviosa but whenever you cast
it it's just such a strange
such a strange like it barely does
anything
and they make it like it's a big deal
they're like hey you're getting this
card when guarding Leviosa to relive
this classic moment from the Potter
series
yeah see here you go causes the club's
troll to float the club's troll the
trolls Club
the float
see watches watches watches
like
it barely even registers I don't
understand
all right so we got to do this four more
times
even though I've already done multiple
exams
none of them count it for some reason
toward progress on this maybe it was
something to do with like the new season
refreshing I don't know
come on troll you shouldn't be able to
see me in here
brilliant
the other one the the charms exam takes
a long time
you have to do like three battles
for each Bogart of each uh person that
you've got with you
oh my gosh Joe you have no idea I mean
you probably you probably do if you read
any of my comments at all
in the lead up to Hogwarts Legacy how
many times people kept saying it's not
levioso
and then you lose track of how many
people are just like
just making the Hermione Joke versus how
many people I actually think I'm saying
it wrong
I'm like no guys
for the last time
they introduced this spell
I mean technically it's part of the lure
levioso just a levitation charm
like see what is the point of that card
man
it just barely does anything
see if we can knock you in there
didn't move him at all
that's fine though thunderstorm should
end it out here
look at that big Damage Big Damage Big
damage nice
revelio
all right two more
I'm glad this is going quick I was kind
of dreading it because I thought it had
to be like new exams
I didn't think it would let me go back
and repeat them
what do you mean you're in cool down
it's a solo mode how can it be in
cooldown
new card obtained oh my goodness you
guys
they're giving us this card just for
this Mission I bet it's really strong
what do you think let's try it out here
oh my goodness it did 54 damage
I wonder if they take increased damage
when they're whenever they're a chess
piece for Ron
how can you see me dude how can you see
me
it's what your Hogwarts legacies started
to do after the last bug fix wait what
do you mean does it it pronounces it
differently
the value of simplicity
all right one more one more on the troll
you don't have to pass them wait what
are you talking about you don't have to
pass what
Pat oh you don't have to pass the exams
no way it's just an attempt
to complete this challenge that's kind
of cool
all right you know what let's try
if it counts attempts I'm gonna try this
one at the highest difficulty just just
to show you guys
how crazy this thing is
all right I'm trying to remember what
deck I ran with when I finally beat it
oh man oh you can't use opal eye on this
one
I feel like I had Pixies bomb box
I can't even remember
let's just stick with Hermione you'll
get to see
you'll get to see how crazy it is level
70 I'm nowhere close to being high
enough level to do it
getting to Diamond level and dueling
you're ever gonna get
hey I could try to help you sometimes
Jenny
if it'll let me join you actually I
don't know if it'll let me join you now
that I think about it
all right everyone I see you right now
not too bad not too crazy right
whenever they start sending out the
Whirlwind
that's when it gets ridiculous right now
look look at that look
are you kidding me you just instantly go
down
okay it wasn't that bad on the a level
that
was even more insane right there
all right so you said that should have
counted
yes all right that one is done
oh what is that
a butter beer barrel never run out of
your favorite refreshment
upgrade any Echo twice on my daily task
attend divination class times three oh
my gosh really
let's see if they've fixed this in uh
in the BlueStacks app yet
in the BlueStacks app whenever I play
the Divination game
the little mini game where you have to
draw
it does not work properly
wait a second did they take off the
classmate
they did I think they took off classmate
assist couldn't you do classmate assist
with divination
thought you could
it's like whenever you have to draw it
it had been completely blacking out the
screen so you can't see anything
it's really weird
see if it does it again
observe the pattern in the crystal Bowl
oh my gosh you guys already know we
can't draw that
and then let's see let's see if it's
nope see how it does that
all right I'm gonna try to draw it
there we go
there we go you don't have the gift a or
maybe that's what it is yeah maybe
that's what it is
no offline roommates now why would they
take that out that was so cool
see how much we get in terms of accuracy
I feel like it's gonna be oh man I
thought it was gonna be like 90 percent
pattern refine with the help of
Professor trolley that looks like the
night bus to me
I'm just gonna go with that though Mia
as the explanation I like that idea I
just don't have the gift for the
Divination
I don't have the sight
as trelawny would call it
I can't believe I have to do this class
three times I could have refreshed it I
guess or something new but
it's fine I could just hang out and talk
with you guys while we work on it
thumbs up yeah see look it even shows
just like a
a little blocked out image over there
so if anybody who
ever was this
maybe there's an update that you guys
could uh push out to fix it by the way
guys if you are interested in testing it
out playing on PC
um BlueStacks
95 of the things it runs very well in
the game and we are an affiliate with
Boost sacks you can look at the
description in the link
the link in the description and the
program's free but if you download it
actually goes to help out the channel
use your inner eye okay okay let me use
my inner eye
maybe this is the time all right we got
a circle and three more circles then a
line through all right here we go here
we go
kind of a big circle like that right
there
okay and then it had that weird little
line in the middle all right all right
and then maybe over here one Circle
two Circle
three Circle there we go
there we go maybe that's it
you have the same issue Roger are you're
running blue Stacks as well right or are
you on a different emulator
yeah it's been like this since launch
it's like the only thing that doesn't
work properly it's so weird like because
it shows the hand too sixty percent come
on
come on
it's like
the house scoreboard
it took me a second on that one I was
like wait what I thought it was candles
or something
because it's the Hermione deck hey maybe
so
that looks like a book
such perfect drawings by our other
classmates
how do you do the high level Dance of
the mouse Anna you don't that is Sal
you don't I do them on my phone
um I have heard that in the official PC
version It's the dancing minigame is is
a little bit different
it's related like I think you have to
push uh keyboard different keyboard
combinations
yep Roger C Roger already knows that's
exactly it Roger you don't that is the
answer all right one more divination
class
we'll be able to check that one off the
list
yeah I think the highest that I've done
on uh
I've done some level three ones Maybe
like clicking around with the mouse
well we got the book this time
all right so let's see we start kind of
right up here
okay start right oh no wait it's not
working
here we go start right there go down
come back up and go back up there all
right then we have like the little
bookmark right here
and we're done that's it
that's it
[Music]
can't move your mouse that quickly
it's not even about that Joe once you I
don't know how how uh
High you've went on the rankings but
when you get to the five stars
it actually like has two on the screen
at the same time and oh we got 70
percent that time two on the screen at
the same time like on opposite ends of
the screen
so even if you were ridiculously fast
and ridiculously precise with the map
it's just like
nope
adjusting the mouse sensitivity so you
could snap around faster no what you
need is to be able to plug in two mice
have two cursors
I think that'd be the only way to do it
yeah some of those level five dances are
ridiculous even on
touch screen
especially if you're trying to get the
top rank
trust me it doesn't work
yeah that's right Anna the ones where
you have to like drag a little bit swipe
come on somebody like my book
like this just beautiful book right here
all right so we should get that complete
so now we can get that reward
nice got some silver keys out of that
upgrade any Echo twice
I kind of wanna
not do that
let's see how much it is I'm hitting
that point where I'm I'm really trying
to be very careful with all of the
resources because
especially with the changes to gold
although I did get a hairy legendary
today but I don't love
I don't really love the cards in it
I mean they're not bad cards but for a
hairy dick
see if the either of these new ones are
any better
not really not for newt
already upgraded those two fully
oh man it's just
like that hairy Echo is better based on
the cards that I use like I at least
have two
Stupify and expulso and then Hermione is
nice as well
you only need to do one level
two times oh
that is also good to know
you know what I need is a uh a legendary
Hermione although my Hermione's PR look
at that dude I got the double the plus
two on thunderstorm with my Hermione
I also use that card a lot
I use that card a lot I use that like I
use I use four of those no I use five of
those in PvP in dueling
and then this one I only use in PVE but
is crazy good
so honestly it would be hard for a
legendary Echo to top that Hermione the
double thunderstorm man that's just like
whoo
that's what makes it really really
strong
you know what let's look at a Snape
let's see if I've gotten a good Snape
I have yet to get a decent Snape card
Snape Echo I mean
whiz bang okay bomb box not bad
actually wait what does she do I think I
think I've heard that she's decent with
Snape
Weasley twins I haven't used them at all
I guess they're kind of a deck that you
could really run any sort of cards with
maybe if you had one with a lot of good
uh echoes
or not Echoes a lot of good um
companions
that you use a lot
Jake welcome back Lottie gives you MP
that's right that's what I was thinking
Jesse yes and they just updated it today
with a the year three storyline
so year one and year two were available
when the game released here in the US
but yeah today they officially added
year three so you can do storyline for
year one year two and year three if you
haven't played it played it yet
yeah not really any good ones there
let's see I haven't done any Neville's
ooh okay I feel like swelling solution
could be something you run a lot with
Neville
oh the the time's too Hagrid right there
is nice
acremental Venom floopers stack of
Monster books
I just need to pick one that I like
might use at some point
okay let's check Dobby
nah I don't I'm never I'm not gonna use
a lot of Dobby
I know it doesn't even cost that much
but
I'd like to pick something that I might
use at some point you know what let me
look at the newts
because I have two legendary newts
surely there's got to be one that's
better than the other I
not really
for a new card they're both kind of eh
I guess I'll go with this one
all right so what you're saying is I
only have to
do it like two levels
it's like that right there would that be
enough
oh that got me one
oh I guess I could have just done it
I could have done it at the lowest tier
couldn't I
oh that's the overall level of the card
I see I thought that was telling me how
many it was adding
all right so it cost me 40 gold
basically to do that
you're working through year three right
now King of the North
nice we've already had a couple people
drop in say they beaten it
I'm gonna I'm probably gonna take my
time with it
all right another daily task complete
looks like everything is good let's
check the season task
clear one team exploration off the path
I don't even have that yet
this one I'm working toward just have to
wait till it's
easy hairstyle
nah I'm good
I'm good
all right so we'll get those two in
I might refresh can I refresh this one
I don't know if I can refresh it or not
it's 104 where you are Jake oh my
goodness
man make sure you're drinking a little
plenty of liquids yeah see it's so
strange that off the path is in
is here but I can't do anything with it
yet
can I not refresh these season tasks
refresh in 12 days
like on your dailys you know if you have
one you don't like you can refresh tasks
but I don't think we can here
no way I guess we have to wait till the
mode gets added
you know what while we're here might as
well claim a little bit more
oh you know what we could do let's try
to do the solo side here
we upgraded our spell book again today I
feel like we should be close to being
able to complete this one
you're still not through all of year two
Jenny no way
trying to play an upgrade to characters
oh that's right I couldn't imagine
wait you can do that do do what
do what Anna
all right any recommendations for this
one guys level 24 they recommend the
Bellatrix Echo but every time I've I've
ran it
it just hasn't done that great for me
let's try it let's try to set one up
oh refresh tasks yeah yeah yeah on the
dailies you can
you definitely can on the dailies
oh okay let's run this Bellatrix let's
run aguaminty
okay we've got augmenti in there
what else would be good
I like I like having a pug no
nebulous we could probably take that out
I don't think that's going to help us
very much
and because Bellatrix we don't want to
run a lot of high MP cost cards I might
do that just because it's really good
for getting the
helping you get your
Death Eater
confringo
Time Turner you know what time Turner
might be interesting here
maybe a Snape Echo with Time Turner
I also wonder how well the floopers do
like can they confuse the dragon I'm
guessing no but
atmosphere charm in
and I use that card enough that I think
I can justify spending the 2000 on it to
upgrade
bloopers are essential so they do work
on them no way okay that's actually
pretty strong then mine are kind of low
but
you know what I might run bloopers
instead of the thunderstorm
okay what are some other low-level
things that I could run here I mean if
I'm going to run flooper should I run
bomb box like this bomb box have enough
time
Maybe expulso
yeah my bomb box is pretty high too
you know what let's go with Pixies
instead of that one
oh I don't need swelling solution
with this deck
you know what let's just throw in the
niffler why not
and I mean I am below the recommended
level so
all right let's go ahead and get them
out
All Right bloopers go to work show me
what did he already take out one of them
he did oh that is pretty powerful I
agree
I'm already seeing the power of the
bloopers right there how they just
completely turned him around like that
oh I forgot to set my
Hermione's probably not the best one
yeah there you go Hermione
get the augments he going
no
oh got both bloopers that's just bad
timing by me
bad timing bad spacing
like my meter's just not filling up
quick enough we're doing decent damage
just not fast enough
nope stay on this side stay on this side
all right this time I'm gonna I'm Gonna
Save the floopers for when he okay wait
maybe we're good maybe we're good
dude every time I drop the bloopers okay
I think they got away that time nice
they did
all right get mcgon go in there come on
McGonagall
transform him
yes
GG Minerva
yeah 20 seconds he's got a land though
we gotta wait for him to land
come on Death Eater where's my Death
Eater get in there
oh the Death Eater just got absolutely
melted I'm just gonna restart it
we gotta we gotta do a better job of um
making sure we don't waste the floopers
throw whatever pops up and you what
level were you hello world when you got
it I'm five below the recommended so
very possible that I am lower than I
need to be dude
using the Bellatrix Echo
stop taking me through this every time
so weird that it makes that pop up every
time
okay wait for it there we go keep moving
keep moving no way
bro how does he Target the bloopers
every time like that
oh that was so bad I just dropped them
right in the flames
just drop them right in the flames
like see watch this every time I go back
in though it's like you should use the
Bellatrix deck
and you have to click in on here even
though I'm already using the Bellatrix
Echo
stop telling me that
for goodness sakes man
all right
okay okay okay wait for it yes yes now
go bloopers go
Hermione
and we're gonna do
oh she didn't even get to cast augmenti
that's so bad
okay don't take out the bombs please
I'd much rather you yeah much rather you
go off to the niffler
instead of the bombs
move
oh we got some floopers if he doesn't
take them both out
okay we got one of them we got one of
them man
and we still have some Cornish Pixies
doing some work that's pretty good
let's get more Pixies going in dude that
one pixie over there was still surviving
foreign
what is this
what did I click on
oh this is good this is good
nice bloopers nice
we just don't have enough time
all right come on Death Eater go to work
go to work go to work
there we go good damage
it's not gonna I'm just not gonna have
enough time man
what do you do when he flies up like
that
and this is one that's basically
impossible once
once the grab horn rolls in
all the multi-hit Spells you have at the
moment and floopers
so probably not bomb box I mean he does
take out the bomb box pretty quick
don't forget about potions you think the
you think the potions would help against
him
maybe uh maybe the one that like
disorients them or whatever
dude this is so ridiculous that it wants
you to use the Bellatrix every single
time even when you have the Bellatrix
Echo selected
oh my gosh should I put the
oh my gosh man
the timing on that
just gonna try to spread out get get
like all these little guys
all across right now
no way that pooper on the right when
so ridiculous dude this is so ridiculous
like every time I drop the bloopers you
can just be assured that
Flames are about to rain down
in that exact spot
doesn't matter how many other things we
have on the battlefield at the time
he is going to focus on the floopers
all right you know what let's get let's
get Hermione out
oh man we got lucky
we got really lucky that it didn't take
her out right there
no
no dude every time I drop the bloopers
I'm just gonna have to wait till a
situation just like that right there
how do I not have more hits on him
all right he's not even looking over
here he's not even looking and he
immediately turns for the whoopers you
cannot make this up dude
somehow Hermione's still alive
I have no idea how she's still living
through this
[Music]
come on McGonagall get him
finally
yeah see we like we should be getting
the Bellatrix the Death Eater much
faster
We're not gonna stand any chance if we
can't get it out faster than that
football
dude he turned away from McGonagall to
focus on the floofer they are definitely
programmed to focus on them
you cannot tell me otherwise
all right we gotta do some crazy damage
right here
all right everyone of course then he
takes flight
uh
uh I think we might be too low level
guys
the clock TurnKey ad popped you up and
popped up on you in the middle no way
fire crabs are tanky and build up
Bella's cage
you know what else I just thought of was
uh
mantical moves
fire crabs aren't leveled up at all
though
they're level five
see okay I'll level them up
let's level them up like maybe twice
500 and 750
yeah I'll do that
level seven
all right let's put you in instead of
augmenti I don't feel like augmenti's
helping me too much also let's get a
different
let's actually run
let's run McGonagall first
you second
maybe Hagrid third
okay what else was I thinking though
right there you said um
when you said fire crabs it made me
think of something else too
that might be a good one to try
because they don't move right right
right
oh what was the other one I was gonna
try
oh acrometrical Venom oh these Manticore
moves
oh I don't want to replace the Pixies
though I'm not really using Expo so
all right let's see how that goes
Manticore moves I can move around a lot
better
see just ignore that like why can't I
just
that should only pop up one time
yes I'm gonna complain about it every
time that we have to do it
it's so ridiculous
all right
now if she could transform him really
quick like that right there that's huge
it's actually huge
nice McGonagall
you know what I'm gonna get the Pixies
almost dead Manticore moves
you can't hit me you can't hit me
no no no
I'm trying to move
bro the fire crabs that might have been
an
a genius play right there
oh the food person
you're a wizard Harry manumax welcome in
thank you for the sub
if that Death Eater actually spawned at
the right time and we got the floopers
that would have been a different story
would you eat McGonagall is still alive
no way
no way McGonagall is still up
oh man I thought that fire crab was I
thought the
yeah it's not a good spot to put it
All Right bloopers get in there
all right well this is by far our best
run so far
we're now I gotta win it but
dude McGonagall is still up somehow
oh man
not for the grab horn
we would have actually had a chance
oh oh oh oh oh
that's the longest I've ever survived
when the grab horn comes out
all right I think I think hello world's
on to something though with the
they're so tanky too
just have to get them in nice and close
to the to the Dragon
yeah yeah yeah surprise surprise
we have to use the Bellatrix echo or
you're recommended to use the Bellatrix
Echo
I also got to make sure that my
Pixies don't die right away
nice get in there foofers
all right now let's get in put the fire
crabs
okay
yes McGonagall
took him down at the perfect time
okay McGonagall didn't last nearly as
long that time but
come on Poopers come on get over there
get over there get over there yes
I'd like to have another fire crab dude
that fire crab still has so much health
and we got a Death Eater now let's go
let's go let's go
yes yes the Death Eaters doing work
oh man 40 something seconds
the fire the fire crab actually survived
that no way
it's probably I probably should not have
used that in Cindy I'm wasting so many
movement cards
we need another fire crab that's what we
need
no
oh dude this is the closest we've ever
been
come on man
get the other Death Eater out
oh he's
that's just not fair when he's not even
oh my goodness
wait
wait where's the grab horn oh there's
the graph horn
dude the Death Eaters are absolutely I
don't know what's going on with the grab
horn
I don't know the grab Horn's just stuck
grab horn stuck we like stunned him
somehow
he's still not moving
the grab porn is Frozen
I'm not complaining
oh no
come on fire crab oh no the crap horn
woke up no
not like this
not like this scrap horn
we're out of movement cards
no
man he was just locked in place
strategy is more hits More Death Eaters
facts
I just need to get a whole
just Army of those fire crabs
how close am I to leveling up
if I could level up one more
oh we are actually really close
look at this
but I would only want to use cards that
I'm actually going to use
Although seeing how these fire crabs are
performing here maybe I want to try it
in uh
in duels as well it's pretty strong
pretty strong
what is the Harris card
Harris
you mean the Harry or fire crab
how much is it to take it to level eight
it's still probably not going to be
enough
oh my gosh I'm gonna regret it but I'm
doing it I'm doing it
do a little more damage fire crab a
little more damage for us
oh Hagrid
maybe maybe it was the Hagrid card how
the Hagrid like dropped in at just the
right wait I thought it oh I switched
decks
I switched decks by accident
oh my goodness man I'm gonna get this I
gotta get this before we end
gotta get this
all right so you're gonna pop up you're
gonna tell me to run a Bellatrix deck
this time I actually need to switch
decks yeah yeah yeah
gonna go down here to our fire crab
all right
battle
Nick
dude that is so clutch when McGonagall
gets him that quick
I'm too old for this
I just have to I use up so many movement
cards I'm gonna try to put out more
nifflers this time
dude we are we are getting
we are getting the Death Eater fast this
time
okay I hate that he already took out our
mcgonagle but
huge man huge the Death Eater didn't go
down
[Music]
I'm saving up man I'm saving up I want
another crab
the thing the fire crabs also do a
really good job at is they they can take
the uh
the lightning hits
really well
meant a cool move moves
no something big is approaching all
right so what we're going to do is we
got to bring out Hagrid again like right
when he when he comes out
like right now okay Hagrid
come on
oh dude maybe that's what it is
dude it's something to do with Hagrid
no
and then once he gets in close that's it
though
he definitely did not stay stunned
nearly as long that time
as he did earlier
new season events what did they did that
just happen Ginny no way
I've been wondering when they were going
to give us new uh
grow Holly with your roommates
I'm wondering if I'm really getting a
lot out of bomb box
what's something that we could throw out
that would give us more hits
oh I bet you're right when that popped
up
I bet you were right
this one might actually be interesting
oh what about a centaur
to like sit in the back off the path is
in there now let's go that's awesome
very very good news very good news
you know what maybe acrobantula Venom is
the play
let's try that
gonna try that I feel like we're really
close we just need need to put out a
little bit more damage
all right right there
all right fire crab your next buddy
you're next I'm trying to save it
now if I could get two fire crabs going
early
that would actually be huge
you still have McGonagall going right
now
no I don't want to walk into the flames
get another acremental venom out there
nice McGonagall great timing
oh man we're about to get a Death Eater
too let's go
yes yes yes the Death Eater is not being
seen right now
thank you
here comes another fire crab
oh no he's gonna do the thing where he
flies and lands now
and it took out almost that full health
fire crab
that's just so unfortunate man like
what are you supposed to do about that
If he if he didn't take flight like that
we would have it
we would totally have it
no don't leave don't leave the fire crab
do not leave the fire crab oh he's gonna
land on the fire crab
of course he is
there he comes man
no stop
you just gotta survive dude
oh put the fire crab down
like as long as we can keep Hagrid up
that's what it is Anna you're a genius
no no no no no no no no
oh or if we get too close like that
come on move it's just like he's one hit
he has one hit
the flying is definitely the worst part
of the fight you were right about that
all right so now we know though if we
can stay away from him with Hagrid even
when the grap horn comes out
we actually still have a chance
I did like having the acromantula Venom
there early we got a ton of damage in
dropping McGonagall first like that
it's like we kind of just walk around oh
yes fire crab at the beginning okay wait
for him wait for him wait for him there
it is all right now McGonagall
in there
fire crab in there
let's go and get a niffler out too
get the acremental of Venom I'm gonna
try to conserve some of my movement
cards too this time
like try to wait until he's locked on to
me
oh this is big man this is really big we
are almost to another fire crab
okay the bad news is he's already taken
out McGonagall
McGonagall was was really strong for us
in that last one
all right well that was kind of a
pointless niffler
nice
nice lots of hits from the Death Eater
there
all right he's probably getting ready to
take flight soon
so I want to be a little bit careful
with throwing out another
let's put out one of the floopers
no dude
it's right in their face
yep there he goes okay I knew it was
coming up good news is we're gonna be
able to throw fire crab immediately
and an acromantula Venom
no you're flying again already
so quick
yeah don't leave that spot do not leave
that spot
oh no we're right by the crap horn dude
literally right by the grab horde
no no no no no no no no no
we can't lose Hagrid
Hagrid is the key to winning this fight
no
oh he's taking flight again
7 000 man
yes Death Eaters go crazy Death Eaters
go crazy please
go
no
dude I meant almost full health in that
grab horn just absolutely wrecks
oh Alicia welcome in the Haggard Strat
is crazy it really is I feel like I need
more damage though I think I'm just too
low level
you can't get through the dragon so hide
there
honestly yeah like I think it's better
to take the fire damage from the dragon
you're probably right
I don't know why stuff like this like
I don't even know what the recommended
level is for this
I'm fine I think I have five below
what's recommended
the other thing is it would be great if
McGonagall would would stay alive longer
okay bring McGonagall in right there
nice go Poopers go go go go go go go go
I'm gonna wait for the fire crab
get out of the way
all right see if we can get a little bit
from the niffler here
since he's not really paying attention
over there right now
all right
go bloopers nice McGonagall transforming
him again
are about to get the Death Eater so I
need to stay on the move here and
another fire crab oh this is Big Time
right here
big big big big big damage right here
let's go
and let's get Cassandra in there
thank you
mcgonagall's still alive you guys that
is great
oh he's about to take flight
he's about to take flight but this has
been a really good one man really really
good one there we go
all right so as soon as he lands we got
a fire crab ready
another fire crab ready to go let's get
a niffler going
okay he said no on the Netflix
he said nah nah nah nah nah no niffler
allowed
no we are taking flight again
foreign
all right hold on how much time do we
have
seven six five four three two one and
there we go
dude
yes oh he's he's wrecking the grab horn
no no man's core man score moves oh he
just went through the dragon Jenny what
was that
you're not supposed to be able to do
that grab horn
gosh that I thought that was the Run
I thought that was the Run
as soon as that came out yeah I think he
already like that time he already knew
where I was he had the aggro on me but
if I can like be behind the dragon maybe
he doesn't know
maybe he doesn't know
all right all right all right
[Music]
could try to trade for some cards with
you guys see if there's anything we
could upgrade
are we close on anything we're close on
acremental of Venom but
all right Walk This Way walk
all right wait for him to do the big
fire that one right there that's when we
bring McGonagall
nice McGonagall nice
all right
fire crab took major damage at the
beginning that's very unfortunate
very unfortunate for our fire crab right
there ladies and gentlemen
the good news is the fire crabs are
pretty durable
all right I'm saving up for this next
fire crab
nice Death Eater right there
oh McGonagall just went down but she was
able to spawn the
Stone Soldier over there we still got
the Death Eater up uh so much for that
so much for that it was nice while it
lasted
all right you guys know what we need
right in there
go fire crab
[Music]
33 seconds and he's taking flight again
we need to get him back over here where
we've got the fire crab
I don't know what to do I don't know
what to do whoopers come on
foreign
four Twenty One
aircraft right on you all right let's go
ahead and get in the cart
did he just knock us out of the car oh
he didn't okay good good good good good
good good
oh big damage
big Damage Big damage
no not the cart
not the cart you don't see me here you
don't see me
you don't see me no fly away
dude if we can get this fire crab out
we're gonna win I'm calling it
fire crab is out
oh no no no no get behind him no what
what the crap horn wasn't even close to
me
it wasn't even close
if we could have got the Manticore moves
out
magical moves
Roger thanks for being here dude thanks
for being here
have a good rest of your night
we're getting this man we're getting
this I thought that was the one
yo Brook Snape welcome in
Brook Snape aka the daughter of uh
Savage Khaleesi
all right we're getting it we're getting
it right here right here wait for the
big fire wait for the big fire there it
is McGonagall you're in you're in you're
in
floopers you're in acrimental of Venom
two
yes I am commentating this like it is a
very important situation here oh man how
you gonna do my niffler like that dude
How You Gonna oh this is bad Magano is
already dead
yeah that's tough probably not gonna get
it this time
even though I said we're gonna get it
we're probably not gonna get it
wait did he just take out the fire crab
too
yeah we're just gonna go and restart
that one
we're just gonna go ahead and restart
wow he took out McGonagall he took out
the fire crab
fire crab is pretty tanky but that time
not so much
have I mentioned how annoying this is
that you have to go and do this like
Echo thing every time
even when you're using the echo guys
when you're literally using the echo
all right McDonald's get in there
you go uh dude why is he taking
McGonagall out so fast now
and what do you have against niffler's
dragon
what do you have against
it
you're a wizard Harry
hey Brooke with the sub thank you so
much Brooke
appreciate you subscribing to the
channel
get in there fire crab and the Death
Eater let's go perfect time spawning in
took out both fire crabs see that's
ridiculous
the mess
that's ridiculous shouldn't be able to
do that
just shouldn't be allowed
oh man I'm spamming now I'm just I'm I'm
not
I'm not being smart with the cards
anymore
he's about to take flight yeah I was
waiting for that
oh he went for the Death Eater instead
of the fire crab
yeah I'm watching The Pixies now that
you mentioned that just to see
all right so we need to start
remembering when where we have him in
terms of damage when the grab horn
spawns in
all right so this time he's at 7787.
we just spawned in two Death Eaters
perfect timing on the Death Eaters
no no no no no
no no
fire crab go do your work
oh we live here we live here man three
thousand seven twenty three come on come
on
I don't like the cards we have right now
no man's core man's core management
romantic romanticore
run away from the grab horn
run away run away run away run away run
away
come on fire crab oh he took flight
again
he took flight again
what a punk
no you don't see me over here crap horn
no
what's happened he did
7743 damage
you gotta be kidding me
oh Savage Khaleesi thank you so much for
becoming a member of House wreck and
tour
Khaleesi and I had a great run a couple
weeks ago in uh duo duo duels in this
game
so much fun Khaleesi thank you for using
that membership here on the channel
enjoy the emotes if you're interested in
our merch at all you also get discounted
merch and you get a special role in
Discord as well whenever you're a
channel member here
oh okay
have I said this is the run a few times
this is the Run
this one right here is the Run all right
wait for it wait for it wait no no no no
no no no no McGonagall get in there get
in there McGonagall now boom you're in
there
niffler live live live live live come on
niffler
all right there we go now that is my
definition of a good start right there
yeah I know it was too much to ask to
have the floopers live too
it was too much to ask
although it is good to see Minerva over
here still living
Minerva very good very good very good
okay you took out one of the fire crabs
why is it saying immune
you should not be immune
I'm kind of wanting to save Cassandra
for when he takes flight
because you know he's about to take
flight
I think I'm just gonna yeah yeah yeah I
was like I'm just gonna see I wish they
would be smart enough to move like move
guys move he's coming in
we didn't actually take out the Death
Eater
he did not take out the Death Eater I
don't believe it
oh he's taking flight again
we're gonna be have him at about the
same damage as before maybe a little bit
more
yeah
oh no that's a bad spawning Point
actually no that was perfect
he didn't even need a Hagrid we didn't
even get to the crap horn
let's go man
oh my gosh who was that though hello
world hello world with the big time Big
Time tip right there
of using
the fire crab
massive massive W using the fire crabs
right there
that was epic dude that was actually
Epic
thank you for the tip all right we're
gonna try one time level 25 just to see
how insane it is just just one time
that's all we're gonna try
because I know it's going to be
ridiculous oh wait oh I can't even do it
yet it won't even let me do it until I
unlock Spellbook level 45.
of course you won't
I wanted to give the people what they
wanted
you're stuck here for a week on that one
yeah I've just I've been taking my time
haven't really been worrying about it
too much oh we unlocked an achievement
too
let's go
get some red hair right here
nah it's not me I like it though
I do like it
yeah that one was tough let's take a
look at the new updates though new
season events
dormitory Co-op what participate in
different in-game activities for plant
care materials raise now
oh wow look at this you get some good
rewards for it too
care for the plant in your dormitory to
get amazing Rewards
the next one is easier is it nice
I just need to I think I think I need to
upgrade like one card and I should be
good the Holly required
didn't even give me time to read
growth rate plus 20 an hour like okay
what do I do here the bane of flesh
eating slugs this repellent can keep the
nasties at Bay
receive more materials how do I do this
building Club what I already did all
this oh but I bet it it just went live
during that update there we go the Holly
requires more care try various
Kevin let me read try various plan
activities such as fertilization weed
removal and Pest Control very nice very
nice
those are some solid Rewards
bin Forest updates okay so let's see if
we can if off the path is in here now
all right so you have let's go ahead and
just claim this
I know I don't have much in there but
all right so off the path must be over
here
oh there it is that's kind of like the
the new deathly Dell I suppose
very interesting
so I'm at level can you do any level oh
after you after you clear that one
where's a little description
okay so time limited Forbidden Forest
stages will refresh after a period of
time seemingly 12 days obtainable only
by teaming up complete within six
minutes
to obtain
so no Echoes or anything looks like you
just compete for Golden Keys
golden key Silver Keys gems and then
thank you notes as well
very cool very cool way easier than
before yeah I know the uh I know these
were a lot easier I've already done my
runs wait
how do I have new lanterns guys
and why do I have three
I already did my two runs for the day
you have five notes so they must have
given us like a three bonus
everybody received more oh
very cool very cool and maybe since I
was already in game I didn't get like
the pop-up or anything
oh man this is so cool this is so cool I
might have to hop on and play some later
but I think that's gonna be it for the
stream today guys thank you so much for
being here man this was an epic epic
stream had a lot of fun playing the new
update uh hope you guys are having a
great week so far stay tuned to the
channel for new videos I'm gonna have
one hitting
probably going to be tomorrow now is
going to try to get it out today
actually I already recorded it it was a
video about the update but it was before
they made all that they added the new
stuff in
now they've added more stuff so I'm just
gonna re-record the whole thing now that
I know a little bit more about it but uh
yeah guys thank you for all the new Subs
uh for Khaleesi becoming a channel
member and all those at the beginning
who were re-upping their membership it
really does mean a lot appreciate all
the support as always thank you all so
much for watching guys I'll talk to you
again soon